plus tout on est reparti dernier jour
parti pour la troisième jour de ce
championnat du monde de partir rapide
donc on peut si vous voulez vous montrer
un petit peu le classement
jusqu'aujourd'hui de savoir ce qui s'est
passé
avant dans ce tournoi alors attendez je
arrive de suite ici
sur twitch
et du coup nous avons en tête avec 7 et
demi sur 9 nous avons 15 scène donc
Arsène qui est qui a vaincu dans ce
tournoi qui est déjà très peu champion
du monde dans cette cadence
donc voilà mais il a quand même encore
3% à 709 à Montreuil le nombre de
joueurs qu'il y a dans ce tournoi donc
on a
à la fois la confirmation et la surprise
à à ce niveau là parce que maintenant il
est plus de 2700 après il y a que des
plus de 2007 ça c'est place là que des
joueurs très attendus
donc c'est déjà une très grosse
performance c'est ce qui va confirmer
aujourd'hui pour cette dernière journée
du championnat du monde de rapide on va
le savoir on va le savoir tout de suite
après on a aussi App Store qui lui est
champion du monde en titre dans cette
cadence donc ça c'est intéressant de le
voir ici
en embuscade pour aller chercher son
second titre champion du monde
il confirme encore son exploit de
l'année dernière déjà et donc on a aussi
fait deux CIF pas oublier Kyo qui est
aussi là donc la nouvelle génération qui
arrive avec gamer App Store off et de CF
quand même hein
de l'an dernier on va dire s'il arrivait
à devenir à devenir champion ça serait
quand même la grosse cote hein
non non pas du tout pas du tout
on a une panoplie de joueurs on a on a
tout bof erikasi artemieviri you Yang on
a Caravana donc ça c'est quand même
beaucoup de joueurs comme habitués des
premières places dans ce tournoi rapide
et reghazi tu vois moi je l'avais cité
en début d'ailleurs je l'avais sur ma
sur ma liste
de club je l'ai laissé cette fois là
dans ce dans ce championnat
ronde et après on voit qu'à 6 points
énormément de joueurs et des joueurs en
plus
c'est encore très très fort mais
d'ailleurs jusqu'à 6 points peut-être
qu'ils peuvent encore gagner mais il
faudra que les mecs fassent trois et
demi ou 4 sur 4
il faut il faut il faut revenir il faut
faire le gros comme bac
il est pas dans les 20 premières places
à mvel hier malheureusement il a perdu
contre iriga easy donc il est à 5h30
il avait jusque là fait un tournoi assez
moyen mais sans perdre et la dernière
ronde de la deuxième journée lui a coûté
très cher ce qui fait il s'est fait
archi dominer de bout en bout par par
erguezi et il a cédé le point entier du
coup c'est ça je pense que il va il va
essayer de faire son mieux aujourd'hui
et se remobiliser pour pour le Blitz qui
démarre demain je fais du monde beats il
démarre demain il est champion du monde
en titre donc il va essayer de se
refaire et
et vraiment faire le maximum à partir de
là aujourd'hui
on se disait c'est que avec stouf bah il
a très peu de chance d'accrocher la
première place peut-être un podium en
faisant 4 sur 4 mais 4 sur 4 c'est très
hypothétique avec les deux premières
journées qui ont été très difficiles
pour lui c'est ça aujourd'hui je pense
que juste il va plutôt penser à se
reposer pour le blesser demain 4 sur 4
c'est c'est
quasiment impossible c'est très très dur
il faut enchaîner quatre parties contre
quatre monstres après c'est possible
Maxime il est capable comme bac tout ça
mais je pense que même lui s'en fout un
peu là je pense qu'il a je pense qu'il a
appliqué dans cet endroit conseiller
même hier s'ouvre de ne pas venir à réel
voilà les coachs les coachs les coachs
du chat
trop se permettre dans ce type de
compétition on rappelle que les joueurs
ont des sponsors ils ont des
financements à différents niveaux de
toute façon même en termes de faire tout
simplement je sais pas je trouve combien
tu as arrêté de tournois dans ta vie moi
j'en ai arrêté un seul pour pour grippe
voilà
et une fois j'ai raté une ronde d'un
Blitz mais en allant prévenir l'arbitre
voilà et j'ai repris le tournoi
d'ailleurs je devais aller voir un match
de foot et le tour est en retard mais
mise à part cela et là on parle de d'un
Blitz c'est pas pareil dans les
compétitions officielles ça n'arrive
jamais quoi
ça doit arriver très très rarement tu as
arrêté les tournois toi stouffe j'en ai
raté de mémoire et là tu me dis 10
j'aurais été mal tu vois
mais en fait depuis que je suis
entraîneur je me l'interdis en fait
parce que c'est montrer un mauvais
exemple
tout simplement voilà tu essaies de
continuer quoi et même pour soi-même en
tant que tel
on doit si on se dit
joueur
de bon niveau expérimenté etc on n'a pas
le droit normalement même pour soi-même
quoi c'est ça doit déjà nous déranger
quoi
mais après une fois qu'on passe coach
effectivement
enfin si mais on a un devoir
d'exemplarités
en tête contre gamer c'est vraiment le
joueur qui qui fait un peu la surprise
jusque là donc 2700 enfin jeune 2700
joueurs allemands il a tout juste
18 ans ou 17 ans je crois
donc c'est vraiment le match un peu de
génération match intéressant à voir donc
personne blanc quand même
en l'an ou en rapide c'est énorme et
puis Carlsen avec les pièces blanches il
est pas facile à battre autant dire que
prendre un demi point c'est déjà une
grosse performance c'est le double qui a
réussi assez facilement hier à museler
Carlsen sur son B3 aussi Carlsen a un
peu plus de fantaisie dans ses
ouvertures que en partie lente il a pas
envie de dévoiler par contre ça c'est
quand même une réalité normalement on ne
va pas défaut aller ses meilleurs
ouvertures même si c'est un cheval du
monde on les garde pour plutôt pour les
parties Nantes
c'est plaisir quand même tu vois il fait
des bonnes parties bien sympa et puis vu
des ouvertures un petit peu excentriques
et alors quoi carwana fait le CDF table
2 et AppStore contre yanguy et
artemiregazi guéri Dubois intéressant
aussi il y a beaucoup de matchs très
intéressant ici et Maxime table 17
contre sargissant donc un jeune joueur
arménien
[Musique]
qui a eu du mal à démarrer aussi un peu
c'est marrant à Maxime il va être
entouré de Naka et de Niman voilà voilà
la place donc ça veut dire que le
tournoi est extrêmement difficile quand
vous voyez que Nakamura sur le web c'est
un avec Arsène je pense que c'est le duo
qui rase tout le monde le monde entier
sur Internet et on voit que Naka est
seulement table 16 avec les Blancs à
côté de Maxime et les deux ne font pas
un gros tournoi pour l'instant très
clairement alors que vous voyez aussi
Sébastien Mazet qui s'est bien glissé
quand même dans ce tournoi il joue table
15 avec les Noirs grosse performance du
joueur français quand on voit qu'il est
au même niveau que
que Maxime et Jules voire plus haut pour
l'instant après deux jours de
compétition tu es quand même une très
belle performance de Sébastien Mazet et
on peut le on peut le souligner c'est ça
c'est ça alors je vais vous remettre la
la caméra déjà
et on espère aussi voir de bonnes
parties parce que pour être tout à fait
franc avec vous depuis qu'on commente
ensemble avec souffle les événements de
chasse.com je suis à chaque fois
émerveillé du niveau de jeu qui est
présenté par les joueurs que soit dans
le speedchait avec des cadences encore
plus courtes ou dans le randoms où on
s'était véritablement régalé cette année
là hier je disais à stouffe c'était une
petite journée franchement
forcément il y a eu des bonnes parties
mais dans les parties qu'on a pu suivre
on est resté un petit peu sur notre fin
il y a eu quelques belles Master Class
quand même j'ai une partie en tête je
crois que c'est Magnus qui hier a
vraiment dans une partie de dominée de
bout en bout mais quand on suivait
Maxime par exemple la dernière partie
c'est très dur à suivre ou il s'est fait
étriper et on a Sébastien Mazet à
l'écran voyage je pense qui est juste
derrière l'arbitre l'arbitre au moment
où j'ai dit ça c'est la cacher voilà la
cacher voilà et après on est là sur
Thomas shevski ancien champion
du monde jeune en 2005 stuff voilà et ça
avait été une énorme partie j'avais fait
nul c'était quand même pas mal mais un
peu arnaqué dans le zenote donc c'était
c'est des beaux souvenirs de voir ses
devoir ses joueurs là voilà voilà ce
tournoi tu fais chaque table tu as une
célébrité là tu as dit galko devant
2005 au championnat du monde tu vois
quel champion du monde c'était un
souffle jouer beaucoup beaucoup de
joueurs c'était superbe ma call écran
aussi qui
vient d'arriver aussi à l'écran ici
contre
le mine c'est
le jour internet on va parler hier
ce genre qui gagne tout
[Rires]
d'ailleurs il est assez bon on a
également sur ce sujet là gros dent donc
des années 90 galfendre
qui est vu le champion du monde
la légende une des légendes présentes
ici il y en a vraiment énormément il y
en a qui sont prêts
ça a commencé et du coup moi je suis sur
on va aller sur
qu'est-ce que se trouve va nous mettre à
l'écran je voulais vous mettre un petit
commencer avec mvl quand même pour
commencer comme ça
je vais vous mettre quand même la
[Musique]
scène qui va avec où on nous voit nous
aussi quand même
je pense que les gens ont envie de te
voir Kevin et oui et je vous ai pas
mentir j'ai mis à la base de finale là
juste une écharpe là j'ai fait la totale
tu vois je me suis dit allez
la veste les chars le conseil du
médecin en tout cas salut penderie
exactement comme ça je me mets bien je
me cale
exactement mais il faisait un petit peu
froid effectivement dans le bureau j'ai
changé de lieu là hier j'étais chez le
paternel donc là j'ai remis les affaires
à la maison et c'est parti
on va envoyer mais je sais que cette
petite veste elle vous fait bien plaisir
donc voilà c'est c'est
jour de dénouement comme tu nous as
disais hier stuff là
je suis désolé de tromper mais j'ai
oublié de te parler de ton rendez-vous
d'après streaming n'est pas un
rendez-vous vraiment galant mais c'était
avec ta conjointe normalement tu allais
à la quincaillerie et c'était comme
important d'en parler je manque à mon
devoir sous je suis désolé alors je vais
quand même dire bonjour amener là avant
de avant de raconter mon
truc
il a réagi au même moment que moi tu
vois c'est super bien répondre alors
juste pour répondre à Charlie Maurice
alors je sais pas si tu connais Charlie
Maurice
mais je sais pas qui c'est en tout cas
c'est un jour de badminton
Facebook hier ça m'a fait marrer mais
comme il s'est passé
moi je le connais
on reconnait un petit peu ses potes
[Musique]
et Charlie on devait se voir mais on
s'est pas vu d'ailleurs bon maintenant
j'ai stream jusqu'au jusqu'au bout du
monde et je crois que Charlie il est
dans le coin de la Bretagne en ce moment
oui c'est ça c'est ça on avait dit on
avait dit
bon là avec ma crève et les streams à
faire bon c'est
ambitieux de se voir mais pourquoi pas
tout reste possible tout reste possible
et du coup quincaillerie alors on était
sur la quincaillerie puisqu'on est dans
une caverne
donc on a le temps de parler de la
quincaillerie
je m'étais fait un espoir avec avec le
bruit de porte comme tu dis peut-être
que elle est allée bon bah il était pas
allé et
du coup j'ai dû y aller après après le
stream
et du coup moi je sais moi j'ai pas très
très bon en terme de travaux trucs
je te rassure là je te dirais bien que
je suis un énorme bricoleur mais bon
et du coup du coup bon ben on a parlé au
gars en plus en espagnol avec plein de
termes que je ne connais pas parce que
j'habite en Espagne je parle couramment
espagnol mais quand il faut des termes
un peu spéciaux de bricolage de trucs et
tout je te rassure je les connais pas en
français non plus les termes donc moi
tout à fait c'est compliqué quoi et au
final
au final il m'a expliqué un truc je dis
ouh très bien ma copine était là aussi à
la caisse j'ai dit bon bah ça va être
bien et du coup on a acheté un truc et
apparemment on a fait un truc qui sert à
rien donc
du coup il y aura il y aura un autre
épisode encore
ce soir vous avez prévu d'éplucher
internet
que tu pourrais expliquer ton problème
réel dans le chat et quelqu'un pourrait
te donner au moins les informations et
le cahier des charges mais c'est
compliqué parce que parce que non mais
c'est compliqué parce que parce que
c'est pas si simple en fait en fait je
voudrais
comment dire je voudrais installer une
je voudrais installer une comment
s'appelle un moustiquaire moustiquaire
mais pas une moustiquaire un truc un peu
plus épais qu'un chat ne peut pas
éclater quoi
ça ça va pas trop ensemble mais quand tu
vas quand tu vas dans les quincaillerie
enfin un truc comme ça en fait les gens
ils te disent juste oui donc je leur dis
non mais c'est pour le chat fait
est-ce que tu as pensé aller voir le
Guide du campeur parce que j'imagine
qu'il y a des campeurs qui ont des chats
et du coup ils ont peut-être des astuces
par rapport à ça non j'ai pas vu mais
bon
mais bon je verrai bien là j'ai
normalement je suis sur un bon je suis
sur un bon truc là mais bon
[Musique]
donc voilà voilà mais bon
donc du coup partenaire bon tranquille
c'est une italienne ou pour l'instant il
se passe pas grand chose
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que c'est la
varente assez moderne avec les noirs
avec A5 qui permet de d'éviter une
expansion blanche parce que un des plans
classiques c'était BK4 avant et
maintenant à 5 est très joué pour éviter
l'expansion blanche
à l'ail dame qui donnait un petit plus
long terme au blanc donc ça y est on
fait des échecs maintenant
et du coup
est-ce qu'on peut dire dans ces
positions c'est qu'en termes de
structure bon il y a toujours la
possibilité pour les noirs de faire des
prends des prends eux mais la structure
s'équilibre complètement et les blancs
ils ont des facilités de pièces ils ont
d'ailleurs 1000 cavaliers B1 en G3 ils
ont fait le plan plus classique de
manœuvre de pièces avec cavalier B1 D2
F1 G3 on a vu ce petit épisode là
et on va dire que les pièces pourraient
arriver plus facilement à l'ailera dans
cette structure un peu figée c'est pas
facile non plus pour
on a par exemple cavalier h2g4 aussi
pour et la dame en F3 souvent c'est du
plan pour vous montrer que les pièces
peuvent naviguer un peu plus vite
sur les cases bien sûr nous montre la
belle case en F5 on a envie d'atteindre
avec le cavalier et avec les Noirs
comment on fait maintenant dans ces
positions souvent on attend un petit peu
on replace les pièces peut-être que le
fou c'est 5 va revenir en F8 et on fait
un fiancetto G6 fou G7 pour contenir
les perspectives blanches sur cette aile
là parce que si on a une structure fixe
au centre ou qui ne bouge pas trop là il
est pas complètement fermé mais elle
peut pas évoluer radicalement à part si
les blancs souhaitent faire eux prendre
des 5 ce qui peut arriver pour gagner le
Pione 5 des fois dans certaines italiens
mais là j'ai pas trop de raison de
donner le centre comme ça ça serait
plutôt en faveur en faveur des noirs
on a beaucoup de coups d'amélioration
lente et ici
bon c'est assez facile comme position
en fait l'expansion blanche avec B4 b4k
mais il faut souligner aussi que A5 ça
donne des cases donc du coup tu vois que
dès qu'il a joué dès qu'il a joué à 5
qui le football est parti de ces quatre
à B5 parce qu'il peut plus se faire
chasser en fait et du coup
il attaque quand même les deux cavaliers
qui eux défendent ce malheureux pion E5
qui pourra un jour pression après
éventuellement une prise en dessin tu
vois
de la colonne donc l'ordi donne souvent
égal ce genre de position sauf mais en
pratique on sait que même un niveau
grand maître c'est très facile à jouer
pour les blancs et que les Noirs
souffrent généralement pour trouver les
idées que trouve facilement l'ordinateur
mais humainement autant voir ce dégager
les beaucoup d'idées chez les Blancs tu
m'as dit la pression E5 j'ai parlé
l'expansion à l'ailera et
malheureusement avec les Noirs je suis
un peu plus embêté pour définir les
plans ici
parce que c'est pas facile de remettre
les pieds sur place
des pièces un petit peu tu vois dans le
tapes t'a parlé de G6 pour restreindre
un petit peu les cases des cavaliers
blancs et mettre le four en G7 en tant
qu'Ato
une bonne décision parce que du coup
c'est vrai que eux pendant 5 sur le long
terme ça arrêterait d'être quand même
une menace avec le pion en prise et du
coup le fait de manger il y a plus de
problème là-dessus maintenant peut
passer à autre chose ils peuvent passer
à autre chose mais j'ai hâte de voir
cette autre chose parce que pour avoir
joué des positions donc l'ordi on voit
la jauge et nous dit égale en plus on a
le droit à la jauge ok bah ces positions
je les ai eus avec les Noirs je suis
plutôt joueur de sicilienne en plus sauf
et quand j'ai voulu surprendre des
adversaires pour éviter des prépas je me
suis risqué à 4 ou 5 sur certaines
ouvertures ça se passe bien mais sur
l'italienne je manque un peu
d'expérience par rapport aux autres
ouverture que je joue et souvent je me
retrouvais en BT dans ces positions que
l'ordi qualifiées des galles pour
déterminer un plan donc on va voir si ça
section
il est plus efficace que moi je n'en
doute pas il est 26 45 mais il jouait un
VL
donc bon
assez normaux ça laisse la place à la
tourment des 8 mais qu'est ce que je
vais faire après concrètement alors que
avec les Blancs je vois beaucoup je suis
beaucoup plus inspiré si tu veux je
trouve
trois tu as eu 31 tu as plein de coups
qui sont assez simples assez bateau
alors pour les Noirs ben Caval il bouge
pas à cause de du Pione 5 qui est
souvent en prise qui avait la patte case
les pièces noires sont marchent un petit
peu dessus en tête je vois un F6 mais si
c'est pas encore ça donne trop de cases
les cases blanches
avec des noirs
pour vous mettre le cavalier quelque
part peut-être en fuite G6 ou peut-être
mais c'est pas simple tu vois c'est
quand même savoir un peu vaincu de
reculer le fou ici
on donne envie de soupirer cette
position avec les Noirs c'est assez
intéressant de voir comment je vais
pouvoir bricoler
la mise en place de mes pièces vers vers
les droits c'est plutôt sympa alors que
j'aime beaucoup les messages de liwi 59
qui proposait de faire une web série des
aventures de stouffe mais mis encore
pendre que s'il voit les choses en grand
il nous dit tellement pas le pilon de
cette histoire mon docteur ça la
référence j'espère qu'ils vont bientôt
la mettre sur Netflix et ça pourrait
peut-être la suite du jeu de la dame en
fait
après faut le vendre à une histoire
comme ça faut la vendre à soupe t'hésite
pas c'est c'est une grosse ça doit être
une super production
[Musique]
je te ferai savoir mais en tout cas oui
je pense qu'il y a pas de souci on
pourra bien s'entendre assez facilement
moi je pourrais peut-être être figurant
le vendeur dans le conseiller le
conseiller
[Rires]
a ta part évidemment parce que tu es
quand même initiative ah oui il y a
viewstick qui propose le titre le jeu de
la quincaillerie c'est pas mal
un peu toute imaginer bon en tout cas
même joue simple le coup de stouf 3 ben
c'est la seule pièce qui ne jouait pas
bon après on pouvait aussi la garder
pour se jeter à ch6 les deux existent
sur sur l'aile sur l'aile mais là il
peut échanger un fou avec l'idée de
faire faux français si c'est de
dénaturer la structure de pion il y a
deux façons de voir les choses manger
plus tard manger là mais
quand tu joues comme ça il y a toujours
des tomber 8 qui peuvent arriver et
attaque le pion est sur un B3 il y a
toujours du A4 en fait la structure de
pion elle va être affaiblie bien sûr
mais ça va donner de l'activité avec mes
pièces noires
[Musique]
qui empêche valait à 4 blancs qui
empêchent un peu les blancs de fixer la
position et qui peut-être menace même
des coups comme tout à 5
pour un jour essayer d'attaquer ce fouet
provoquer éventuellement en échange qui
bloquerait un petit peu la position
dedans
tout à fait à 4 aliments tes tours B8
finalement c'est vraiment
a fait une explication qui qui est très
représentative de la situation
à 4 c'est un coup en prévision de la
prise en C6 il faudra jouer dynamique
avec tour B8 donc il alimente les futurs
tourbes 8 avec ce à quatre je trouve que
c'est très bien joué
même si je préfère les blancs ici parce
qu'ils font un peu ce qu'ils veulent et
franchement vieux style quincaillerie
quincaillerie Gambit ça reste pour moi
le meilleur titre jusqu'à présent plus
ça fait une version assez internationale
donc je pense qu'on va démultiplier les
gains avec ce titre donc c'est super
c'est super et en tout cas bon c'est une
partie assez intéressante quand même
pour mvl là
en tout cas j'aime bien l'amélioration
lente c'est assez pédagogique c'est ce
que fait très bien Carlsen d'ailleurs
dans ces parties
[Musique]
on prend on a la paire de fou c'est très
ouvert et si tu refuses l'échange et ben
il faut bouger la dame et
du tout
moi j'aime beaucoup l'idée ce qu'il
faudra bien en observer c'est les E4
éventuels sur les fous prends F5 parce
que c'est toujours très difficile à
évaluer
et d'autre part
c'est vraiment embêtant plus le fait que
la paire de fou peut être échanger ça
fait beaucoup de réactions dynamiques
cette position je l'aime bien si elle
est figée mais elle n'est pas figée dans
le marbre et c'est un peu le
la crainte que j'avais dans cette
position c'est à dire que le Pione 4
devient boucher les cases blanches
stouffe
dont les blancs devaient profiter à fond
donc sans un coup E4 et si j'arrive à
mettre un cavalier en 4 pour être
caricatural avec les Blancs bah je
trouvais que c'était la régalade et là
ce E4 très dynamique chamboulé la
position c'est pénible parce que je
pensais même à ça ça
ça ça a été 4
on échange tout marche intermédiaire
parce que j'aurais [ __ ] en purement
par exemple qui avait des cadres non la
position finale que tu obtiens je ne
suis pas très sûr parce que je
l'utilise ton tour B8 de tout à l'heure
à ce moment-là parce que je suis pas
pressé de jouer cavalier F6 comme je
sais pas trop le mettre le cahier des
selles je le bouge pas tomber vite je
suis sûr et pas très je suis pas certain
de cette position une structure elle est
bizarre mais il y a quand même du jeu
sur le plomb B2 c'est pas simple on a
des tours 5 des cavaliers F6 des
cavaliers 5
mais je pense qu'il va falloir manger
ensemble parce que si il mange pas ceci
là pas embêté
la création d'un pion isolé à un moment
donné en D4 et si je vends des deux
bâches quand même sentiment que c'est un
petit peu
faible tu vois
un jour intéressant je pense que
cavalier F5 c'est une imprécision forte
précipiter peut-être plus en fait si tu
veux ici j'ai pas de d'urgence de jouer
cavalier F5 alors je c'est sûr que
Maxime il a regardé E4 puisque c'est
typiquement le coup qui jouera la gay
noir c'est si vous voulez il faut avoir
un sens de l'initiative du dynamisme
pour jouer des coups comme carte quand
vous voulez que cavalier F5 pour
l'avantage long terme de la paire de fou
vous êtes obligé de regarder E4 qui
chamboule un peu à nouveau la position
une sorte de double évolution
structurelle il y a eu le E prend F5
d'abord et puis le E4 ça change encore
la structure et il devait de l'anticiper
je comprends pas trop
[Musique]
d'ailleurs il réfléchissent assez
mauvais signe pour Maxime qui peut jouer
très vite qui sont bien en position ça
doit le faire sur quatre mais il avait
forcément anticipé et après il a
peut-être mal jugé quelque chose
en tout cas c'est bizarre ouais c'est
cavalier F5 c'était évidemment une clé
de la position mais pas faire tout de
suite enfin bon après Maxime extrêmement
fort mais là je ne comprends pas je peux
pas vous dire ce qu'il a dit
et généralement si il enchaîne pas
l'écouter un peu en tout cas rapidement
c'est que il a pas forcément anticipé
tout bien les choses en plus il a un
énorme instinct et je dirais
qu'intuitivement cette position elle les
fait pas très saine avec les Blancs bon
est-ce que vous voulez qu'on aille voir
un petit peu ce qui se passe chez les
Français on peut aller voir un petit un
petit Sébastien Mazet
ouais ben alors Sébastien c'est quand
même le joueur français qui réussit pour
l'instant son championnat du monde de
rapides très clairement c'est un
excellent Sébastien quand il perd il
perd que contre des gros joueurs
il a eu l'occasion de jouer les
meilleurs joueurs du monde c'est pour ça
qu'il est venu
il a joué il a joué mvl je vous rapporte
d'ailleurs c'est des fêtes c'est guyri
artemiev du Booba qui est bien pour lui
parce que dans le sens il a rien à se
reprocher il a perdu vraiment contre des
Top 50 mondiaux voir top 30 quoi c'est
c'est top et là il joue à nouveau
Richard rapporte
donc là bon ça positionne
les
noirsolino avec Google 5 et 6
et là du coup il joue avec
donc c'est
bon prendre de l'espace à l'aile dams
pour casser un peu la structure voilà
plein de fois comme ça bon là il a joué
avec avec un cadre qui est
dans les ressources
à jouer pour les blancs
et donc là il a joué avec fantôme
c'est le long chemin du cavalier
le problème de la position c'est le fou
G7 muselet et du coup on va jouer avec
cette pièce un petit peu en moins et du
coup c'est un petit peu désagréable et
il faut trois dames des deux vous
comprenez aussi ça musel le petit noir
c'est ça la question après maintenant
attention au pion des trois bien sûr
avec la proposition
mais
il va commencer par échanger
un cavalier
et après qu'elle va les prendre sous
prank c'est quoi son idée
là le problème c'est que j'attaque 7 et
que sur tour D7 il y aurait E6 comme une
attaque de nuit moi j'ai mon fougé 5 en
l'air j'ai vu et puis on prend aussi je
peux jouer juste pour
je pense que c'est une des clés quelque
chose comme ça alors j'ai mon pion B2 en
l'air mais je pense qu'il est pas trop
comestible tout est dans le pas trop
faudra vérifier quand même il est même
du tourbillon peut-être qu'il est
possible
[Musique]
tout à fait c'est vraiment dur du coup
il ajoute la vallée des quatre pour
garder les cavaliers et dame D1 donc là
du coup on va préparer ces trois
si c'est une menace stratégique sauf
dans ces positions là
il faut
la prévenir je sais pas comment si on
joue nous-même E6 si le problème du
Piona F7 en l'air
c'est tellement moche 6
pour échanger ce fou ici malheureusement
il a oublié un petit quelque chose sans
doute
il y a le pion en fait il a
blender on pense qu'il a blender
le capitaine Sébastien Pascal là il a ta
reprise vous voyez
cette fourchette quoi il y en a
peut-être certains d'entre vous qui
comprennent que la faute est assez grave
assez lourde pour un joueur de ce niveau
comme Seb le problème c'est que Richard
rapporte lui a mis une énorme pression
stratégique sur les aspects structurels
et du coup vous pouvez dégoupiller faire
la face à la pression stratégique et
faire traiter le petit problème et en
avoir un autre beaucoup plus gros c'est
exactement ce qui est en train de se
passer et maintenant bah c'est c'est
presque abandon cette position
on va aller voir un peu le jus de ce que
ce qui nous fait Jules elle est noir
n'oubliez pas aussi que c'est rapide
donc quasiment les meilleurs joueurs
mondiaux donc en fait ils vont très vite
donc ça il est obligé de suivre la
cadence pour pas se retrouver en Ultra
zinote parce que c'est pas un genre de
Bullet le gars sceptre c'est plutôt un
joueur il joue vraiment aux échecs avec
des principes stratégiques forts etc
donc on ne ce type de joueur qui sont
très complets il est obligé de surjouer
en termes de rythme et des fois ça donne
ce qu'on vient de voir des des
erreurs des erreurs plutôt sur l'aspect
tactique voilà et on part chez Jules
avec une ouverture très très modeste de
la part des blancs il retourne dans un
début de Londres avec un C3 très rapide
donc je vais assez rapidement pour voir
un peu et
c'est marrant parce que Max joue très
modeste puis après blanc j'écarte je
pense que ça c'est pas trop de sens avec
le Centre pas fixer comme ça enfin on
peut jouer un souffle mais c'est pas le
vrai jeu quoi c'est pas du jeu pur oui
bien joué c'est clair là vous voyez que
le roi est pas développé mais après il
reste quand même il a toujours des idées
évidemment mais remarquez quand même la
belle idée de de Jules qui a montré à
son adversaire
qu'il fallait mettre en place une
réaction centrale face à au plan elle
dame
enfin sur le roi généralement enfin la
réponse c'est réagir au centre tout le
temps avec le pion donc poussez le
centre ouvrez le Centre quand on se fait
attaquer pour avoir du un contre-pouvoir
si vous voulez on appelle ça le contre
jeu aux échecs
et salut à tous ceux qui arrivent
gris on va aller voir on va aller voir
aussi ce qui se passe à côté
apparemment tu dis qu'on m'entend pas
très fort mais il n'y a pas eu d'autres
personnes à se plaindre ou alors c'est
ma voix
j'ai augmenté pendant qu'il a dit ça
est-ce que
ça va mieux les enfants je leur ai monté
souvent je suis un peu plus fort que je
touche par expérience
toujours et ça c'est froid et puis c'est
ma veste un peu fétiche pour les c'est
un peu la veste de costume en fait que
j'ai mis guilga c'est c'est la doudoune
qui fait plaisir souvent c'est c'est
franchement ma tenue qui marche le mieux
dans le chat donc les remises parce que
c'était la dernière journée du
championnat du monde de rapides demain
je mettrai autre chose vous inquiétez
pas et pour bien sûr dernière ronde
enfin dernière journée de [ __ ] c'est
pareil c'est le costume qui est de
rigueur le dresscode quoi le dress code
du streamer stuff
on comprend absolument rien ce qui se
passe je suis intéressé pour cette
partie là plus ça a commencé par quelque
chose d'assez
tranquille ouais
et de beau faire
déménager un petit peu les blancs les
blancs qui ont l'avantage d'un pion ici
qui avait l'écran ici puis on prend ses
6 et le pion des quatre reprises
maintenant et aussi le pion c'est 6 en
prison
oui c'est pour ça ça me pose question
qu'est-ce qui est prévu sur Full
français
une qualité vous voyez pour prise
d'apprent ouvrir les cases ventes mais
non mais vite et tu as un problème sur
le plan des 4 ouais je voulais le rendre
et sur un coup comme E3
qui pourra plus OK et après je vais
faire 5 pour trouver la position
surprise il aime beaucoup les ouvertures
un petit peu
marginal un petit peu
intéressant donc il faut au 3 tu vois
des champions fois je crois c'est
intéressant parce que j'ai un problème
avec sorte de cours aussi enfin une
position symétrique qu'on subit beaucoup
normalement guéri a joué ça pour avoir
une potion à deux résultats comme les
aime Magnus et là on n'a pas du tout ça
on a un véritable combat de rue
pour jouer au roi F2 et essayer de
les blancs sécurisent la position ils
ont gagné
mais il n'a pas laissé faire donc
le pion F2 et pas manger en deux quatre
parce que ça le guiderait d'être trop
les pièces
juste faut prendre ces deux et en fait
les pièces échanger trop vite
salut à tous
et mal et ça serait pas si étonnant
parce que ça commençait à déconner quand
on l'a lâché pour aller voir on va aller
voir cet après
c'est vraiment
[Musique]
vraiment le fou de guéri et après
c'est normal
le pion des 4 sur échelle ou même tout
reprend des quatre elle est intéressant
aussi les joueurs ont vraiment des
objectifs radicalement posés les Noirs
c'est plus vite la partie va s'envenimer
plus vite à le finira à l'inverse les
blancs veulent une calmer le jeu et
gagner sur le long terme avec leur
avantage matériel du coup du Booba c'est
extraordinaire ce qui vous montre là
c'est la Master Class de sacrifice
professionnel c'est le troisième
sacrifice de pion positionnel pour
ouvrir les lignes et aller scalper le
roi blanc c'est ça donc là pour
l'instant guérit à trois pions de plus
et un quatrième emprise
mais par contre son roi vous voyez son
roi il est très faible et du coup il y a
des machins qui va arriver grâce à E5 a
un découvert un petit peu et les lentes
de développement tandis que les plein
d'avance
Charline s'y est pas trompé
de
se ronger comment je prends pour les 15
noirs quand même ouais mais après tu
prends quoi
pour les menaces
j'ai 5 3 très concrètes
parce que je ferai d'arme G5 il faut
prendre je sais pas mais
[Musique]
on doit jouer sur les cases noires et
j'adore cette position avec les Noirs
franchement j'ai l'impression
pour dame G5 aussi en menace je sais pas
c'est une vraie menace
il faut quand même voir qu'il a quand
même encore trois pions noirs
sécurité du roi c'est le critère numéro
1 stratégie donc ça compense on voit que
c'est chaud il y a des menaces là il y a
des menaces c'est compliqué et puis en
rapide on voit en plus que diri ici à
juste une minute trente à la pendule
contre 6 minutes 30 c'est hyper
intéressant genre fou R2 il y a toujours
G4
c'est le matin chez moi il est 1h de
moins que chez vous en plus sachez-le
ça me va bien ça me va bien il est
encaissé la tour ok donc là je pense
obligé tu reprends il y a trop de
d'échec là-haut en fait et du coup dame
prend c'est beaucoup de menaces
c'est logique les cases noires sont
trouées donc on donne une qualité pour
les cases noires pendant une qualité
bien sûr donc c'est une tour contre une
pièce mineure en l'occurrence un fou
mais là le fou noir va primer ici on va
tout de suite le voir alors que la tour
H1 qui est en plus
à qualité d'avance elle est là ça sert à
rien quoi la tourage
donc
l'idée c'est que je mange un pion et si
tu manges madame et ben c'est moi
je sais pas si ça marche
je sais pas du tout si parce que là on
est sur l'ordinateur bravo et ça a l'air
en tout cas ça sympa
après un problème
de pour filer à l'anglaise
dans les courants d'air mais bon j'ai
plus de tour enfin bref
c'est une partie de cache-cache qui qui
est entamée
à Tourcoing F4 Tom D5 échecs
solide et
au final moi j'ai plus euh
j'ai dame G5 roi F2 dame j'ai de roi E3
ça va être ça va être du délire pur ça
ça en plus
qui appartient en Détroit j'ai faux F5
là non
avec mon fou là alors est-ce que je peux
faire sur X6 F4
Tom G2
j'essaie parce que c'est très très
bouger un peu les pièces parce que là
c'est un peu compliqué pour vous je sais
ça se voit que c'est le matin
parce que qu'est-ce qui arrive à souffle
derrière os le guerrier rose des
Canaries ce n'est pas pour moi c'est
pour le chat parce que là c'est vrai que
c'est ça fait beaucoup de coups voyez
sur 3D 3 j'ai euh
donc j'étais assez content
et du coup bah F4 tu dois faire les F4
qui est c'est changer les pièces sur ton
point F4 tu m'as fait un prends j'ai
deux qui est très bien vu
avec vous voyez la dame qui est encore
en prise et ben pour toute dire j'avais
pas vu
partir mais c'est mieux d'en prendre F4
bravo très jolie coup je n'ai pas vu du
tout et du coup
on a toujours de la chance attention
si ça marche tu es bien parce que du
coup bah tu me laisses quand même tour
j'ai un qui gagne la dame non mais la
ressource elle est incroyable de trouver
ça parce que il avait pas beaucoup de
temps en fait c'est clair en plus
pour l'instant et je pense que
il était obligé de calculer en pure et
c'était pas très dur de voir qu'il était
foutu donc il a forcément vu F4 après
j'ai quand même du foot qui avait l'air
sympa même tout F4 premier qui empêche
F4 tu vois voilà moi c'est joué mesdames
et voilà 6 derrière en tout cas c'est
extrêmement chaud à partir
c'est que la partie tu vois enfin nous
tout ça on le voit on analyse mais eux
pendant la partie et ben ils sont ils
doivent le voir ils ont pas besoin
d'analyser etc enfin je veux dire nous
on est deux tu vois on est à deux on
discute on voit le truc mais eux tout ce
qu'on dit mais il le voit en fait
c'était beaucoup plus difficile
d'ailleurs pour une série de voir parce
qu'il avait plusieurs choix plusieurs
coups candidats il l'a vu très vite avec
une pression au temps monumentale et une
pression depuis le début de la partie ou
du bof et en train de jouer une partie
de grand génie quand même hein
[Musique]
j'irai il sort il sort une énorme partie
de défense parce que je peux vous dire
que c'est pas facile dans la tête et sur
les prix pour pour guéri il faut pas
qu'il enfin en fait la les deux peuvent
blender ils ont plus beaucoup de temps
la pendule et la position est tellement
tellement compliquée que c'est
clairement la partie de la ronde
d'amh43 on va on va retourner quand même
sur Maxime après avoir ce qui se passe
parce qu'on est intéressé par le joueur
français mais faites cette partie là
elle m'intéresse particulièrement
ce n'est pas gagné mais il paraît moins
mal embarqué et c'était très dur pour
mvl qui a de la ressource évidemment on
va aller voir
il est en pleine partie en pleine partie
avec une finale
qui a l'air
il a joué la position isolé considéré
que c'était le mieux tourner c'est 6 ou
C4 donc ça c'est près normal et le fou
qui est presque perdu mais heureusement
qu'il a A3 avec ce petit X à deux qui
est qui est possible et prise prise Tab
4 ah ouais donc il a un pion de moins
mais bon c'est des pions qui vont qui
vont sûrement tomber
sur ces cas d'un B2 il prend il récupère
le pion ok bon il a toujours été
simplement un bien mais c'est pas non
plus
si grave quoi la tête G4
[Musique]
donc bon il pourrait même peut-être
arnaquer son adversaire je suis pas sûr
alors les dessins qui tournent le mien
j'ai quand même du alors je sais pas en
quel sens et ça du coup ah oui oui c'est
certain
mais bon peut-être pression
noir qui a fait une très bonne partie
qui a sorti une belle après
si le débriefait en conférence de presse
il dirait que cavalier F5 c'était trop
hâtif ah oui non mais c'est ça je suis
d'accord
je suis d'accord donc oui un Maxime on
sent une petite nul rapide qui va qui va
arriver
est-ce que d'ailleurs le cameraman s'y
trompe pas il nous montre la partie de
Dubois et guéri et d'ailleurs Charline
vous fait une belle Giroux meilleur
attaquant j'irai meilleur défenseur
voilà
salut comment vas-tu
à tous ceux qui nous rejoignent
et je dis pas loin qui nous a appelé à
parler d'un match de Boden est-ce qu'il
a été visionnaire non c'est référence à
cette partie avec la paire de fou
braquer sur le roi
on voit très bien malin c'est le matin
c'est la dernière jour le dernier jour
de partie de partir rapide du coup
donc on est assez
content de pouvoir couvrir l'événement
en tout cas bah oui là c'est le vraiment
le beaujou le ouais le bonjour alors
qu'hier les parties avaient été un petit
peu décevantes en tout cas celle qu'on
avait suivi
mais là on voit véritablement du Beaujeu
et on n'a pas jusqu'à présent vu ce que
donnait carlossen j'ai juste vu une
petite victoire de dépôt et une nulle
d'abdosauroraf qu'on est yangi et une
époque qui se
replacement
[Musique]
il a complètement déconné qu'on a d'où
ça t'auras alors qu'il avait la mamie
sur la position il a donné la partie en
deux coups ça va te coûter des subs tout
ça mais je sais bien je sais bien c'est
pour ça que je dis ça je l'ai encore en
travers
déjà j'ai mal à la gorge et en plus en
plus il me fait ça terrible
bah merci de devin pour ton pour ton
petit message c'est cool et marée basse
pour mvl ça sent pas très bon ce que
nous raconte ça sent les algues
visiblement non mais en fait ok mvl on
va faire une je pense que oui non là je
pense que 100 fois un peu je pense
qu'objectif d'aujourd'hui c'est de
perdre le monde d'énergie possible pour
pour se reposer pour le but qui commence
demain en fait je vous rappelle quand
même que Maxime est champion du monde de
Blitz et là vu le tournoi qui est
effectivement pas terrible pour lui je
pense qu'il faut juste se reposer et je
tranquille donc là aujourd'hui je pense
pas que vous allez voir du grand maximum
je pense que vous allez vous allez juste
assister à un tournoi tranquille où il
se prend pas la tête et il va faire des
nuls sans trop se soucier de tu vois de
la qualité des parties etc là on voit
qu'il a un petit peu lâché
mais je pense que il va jouer tranquille
il pas vraiment avoir la pression du
résultat et tout ça il va jouer vraiment
tranquille pour garder ses forces pour
pour demain c'est comme ça un peu que
que
je le vois
merci à toi de devoir pour le petit mot
sur la plateforme ça fait plaisir
je vais prendre une défense quand on
peut gagner avec n'importe quel
ouverture de toute façon un Gaston parce
que je conseille aux joueurs amateur ou
débutant
que je trouve que sur le long terme mais
pas si facile à exploiter mais ça peut
ça peut être une bonne ouverture pour
démarrer rapidement d'avoir un petit peu
de connaissances théorique voilà voilà
vous avez vu le chemin du roi d'ici
enfin il est parti de à moins il était
en géant
et il est revenu là et revenu là et là
il va encore repartir on sait pas encore
où là
là j'ai peut-être eu
[Musique]
il va mourir le roi de guéri là je ferai
dame F4 je pense pour amener peut-être
du monde à la fête
ça peut faire pas mal de pièces quand
même on va ramener pas mal de pièces
mais le roi qui est
très très vicieux je sais pas comment on
fait sur dame 7
avec un bâton à trois
pièces
peut revenir
et franchement partie monstrueuse de de
[Musique]
en cas d'échange en B3 de pièces c'est
bien mais il y a dame aussi à la fin
voilà c'est jouer et
tous les pions sont éparpillés donc en
abandon très rapidement après
ce que le roi est encore dans les
courants d'air donc il va il achète des
pions et d'ailleurs guéri abandonné
énorme franchement partie monstrueuse
les gars cette partie là
partie là on va refaire rapidement
du bof qui a sacrifié
prépare et il a tenu le choc
à défendre qui est juste monstrueuse
c'est vrai qu'on l'a vu au speechasse
franchement des défenses de folie la
séquence F5 pour attaquer le fou du 2e
pion F4 plus 5 pour ouvrir les lignes
c'est juste monstrueux quoi et après
derrière prise d'Ama H4 voilà ton
premier truc ça fait une qualité
et les blancs se défendent comme ils
peuvent mais en fait le roi noir le roi
blanc est beaucoup trop faible ou avec
le roi noir
par
raison il dit que c'est incroyable et
qu'on s'était un peu plein de du niveau
d'hier et du coup qu'on a été entendu
par par danyl et effectivement non c'est
clair c'est ouf et guéri d'ailleurs il
se rend compte de la performance de son
adversaire puisque effectivement il a
perdu avec le sourire comme vous nous le
dites et ils sont en train d'analyser
rapidement à l'oral
hyper avec les Blancs ça doit pas lui
faire plaisir mais sur le compte de la
performance
comme ça une raclée comme ça franchement
tu acceptes que bah écoute ça aurait été
meilleur que toi quoi tu vois c'est
aussi un signe aussi de faire super
il se rend compte de la perf donc juste
Maxim nul donc c'est la guerre aussi de
le gain de carwana et le gain de
carlosen
ça a fait nul mais comme on l'avait dit
à cette
c'est tranquille jusqu'à Arsen on va
voir rapidement si tu as la partie parce
que c'est une partie qui est intéressée
particulièrement le match des
générations donc ça commence par une
sorte de catalane il y a pas rigoler
déjà dans l'ouverture Magnus 5 là il
joue là il joue pas B3 il joue la vraie
ouverture et le il le prend au sérieux
il est quand même en tête tiens roi E3
qui a un coup assez assez marrant
on a le droit de centraliser s'il y a
plus la dame
il y a une pièce mineure d'échanger et
il estime que son roi 3 ne peut pas être
agressé donc magnifique c'est ça
mais bon donc là tu vois tourner vite il
y a un vis-à-vis comme ça et il faut
défendre ce pion et si je fais 3 on va
sûrement se prendre une bon un petit C5
qui va qui va arriver je vais essayer et
le pire des quatre va être vraiment sous
pression encore une fois le vis-à-vis de
cloître etc et du coup si tu crois c'est
trois pour défendre ben il y a vis-à-vis
qui est ici donc c'est ça
en plus voilà mais la roi E3 je mets le
roi donc sur une case on va dire
centrale comme tu l'as dit mais je me
bloque le pion en fait donc c'est c'est
logique mais d'un côté c'est aussi un
peu bizarre tu vois j'ai la question
combien calcule les joueurs de haut
niveau donc dans les parties tactique
ils peuvent calculer très loin même
suite de 10 coups ça leur fait pas peur
mais c'est rare mais souvent des suites
de 3 à 5 coups et là ce qui est assez
important de relever c'est que Magnus il
a au moins vu à partir du 10e coup cette
position et en jouant Cavalia 3 il avait
déjà anticipé d'un Massac échec
l'échange de dames des deux
le coupe petit roc et cavalier prend
apprend C4 et tour D8 pour faire roi E3
donc ça fait en fait une séquence en
matière de stratégie importante après
possible aussi que soit une position
qu'il analysait qui connaît à ça non
probablement mais c'est assez rigolo
donc
là il va venir se tenir le cavalier en 5
et en fait au final ben il finit par un
peu museler les Noirs vous voyez tout à
le fou c'est 8 qui qui ne peut pas se
développer les pièces qui vraiment ont
pas on peut d'espace avec les avec les
Noirs donc les rois F7 cavaliers à 5
fois R3 donc il défend ses pions F2 plus
tard il va améliorer la position
tranquillement et il va être un caméléon
c'est 5 peut-être même pousser des pions
de ce côté là attaque de minorité c'est
c'est tout à fait normal on dit que la
Catalane c'est le jeu contre le foot C8
et ben regardez le fousset 8 de Vincent
Kemer dans cette position bah c'est la
tristesse il y a pas B6 à cause du pion
c'est 6 donc il y a pas de sorte de
sortie
et du coup il met tous ses pions sur
noir B4
maintenant on voit que les galipion
doublé chez les Blancs mais mais il y a
la colonne B qui est ouverte et aussi je
dirais des fois un petit assist qui peut
être joué un peu vicieux l'idée c'est
vraiment de casser la structure ici
en tout cas elle a fait pire après même
la rupture A6 en fait souffre aussi qui
menace enfin un peu de potentiellement
dans cette position c'est très
intéressant
donc par exemple sur assise bon tomber
un jeu pour l'instant parce que c'est la
fourchette
il arrive toujours à te mettre à te
mettre la pression mais tu vois c'est
vraiment un jeu tranquille lent hyper
positionnel et c'est assez incroyable E4
KBC 7 3 E3 donc il arrive maintenant
vous voyez le roi est en E3 comme tout à
l'heure sauf qu'il a réussi à remplacer
le pion en E4 plus logique incroyable
mettre contre amateur et là c'est donc
le numéro à mondial contraint des plus
forts jeunes qui existent même de tous
les temps quoi c'est incroyable c'est
juste incroyable
donc là il laisse qu'avec des cinq alors
c'est un coup que je répète que j'aurais
pas fait que blanc parce que j'aurais je
me serais dit que ça donne la case des
cinq quand même mais il voulait faire la
masse l'orgasme bon cavalier comme
mauvais fou maintenant
manger avec le fou parce que du coup il
considère que ce fou E8 bah il fera pas
grand chose même si il sort par là il
faut pas grand chose il mangera pas un
pion en tout cas voilà donc il y a eu ça
on prend la colonne C on mange du pion
des bien sûr il y a un pion passé pour
les Noirs mais l'idée c'est mettre le
roi en Descartes bloquer tout ça avec le
roi en finale le roi c'est une pièce qui
joue active tout le temps roi
U8 tours C5 D4
est perdu hein c'est c'est le roi des
quatre centralisé sur le pion des quatre
perdues et maintenant c'est la masse
comme ça il y a la fourchette
donc on descend comme ça tourbé 5 le
clouage B6 qui exercice et maintenant en
fait vous voyez que les pieds
défenseur le pion on va juste le
cueillir donc tout RS5 intermédiaire
pour aller se venger sur les pions de la
septième donc il y a eu 6 pour empêcher
tout ça et si la tour bouge je mange
aussi du coup il y a plus
tour à vous
et là je mange ici je te laisse je te
laisse même pas remanger parce qu'il y
aura échec je prends la tour et je vais
savoir au final de pion si j'ai un pion
de l'avance bref elle a gagné 120
réfléchir donc on apprend il y aurait
échec enfilade et ça change les tours et
j'ai un peu en avance donc c'est facile
le niveau le niveau est juste la partie
ça franchement vous voyez tout à l'heure
je crois que c'est le plus profond de
bois qui disait que c'est la plus belle
partie qui l'ai vu dans le tournoi parce
qu'en fait nous en fait les amateurs on
est beaucoup plus impressionné par des
parties avec un sacrifice avec un roi
qui se balade etc donc la partie de bof
elle est bien sûr hyper impressionnante
mais moi en fait je vois cette partie là
bah à l'impression encore plus si tu
veux que celle de bof parce que
positionnellement c'est juste un
massacre c'est une Master Class quoi
c'est juste c'est c'est trop beau ce que
personne arrive à faire si tu veux c'est
c'est une mort un peu plus lente tu vois
il y a quelques années j'avais tenté par
un grand maître qu'il disait que moi
j'aime alors caricaturer un petit peu
les différences enfin les différents
styles aux échecs et il me dit que moi
je vais avoir tactique et je suis un
joueur qui aime le sang tu veux et qui
aime bien tuer ma ma proie bah genre
couteau quoi par exemple il me dit qu'en
fait c'est encore plus beau c'est
étouffé tu vois genre l'asphy et en fait
il dit bah la sexy c'est encore mieux
c'est pas de trace tu vois et en fait il
comparé ça il disait ben tu vois là car
Hassan il a gagné par asphyxie et en
fait du coup c'est bah c'est juste trop
trop beau le fait de voir de voir qu'il
gagne alors que le mec en fait il arrive
pas à bouger ses pièces il arrive pas tu
vois et je trouve la comparaison assez
sympa même si on pense que je suis un
peu psychopathe peut-être maintenant
mais c'est pas du tout
je t'imaginais plutôt en boîte de nuit
et puis tu as deux styles de ce
d'ambiance et pour moi les deux parties
qu'on vient de voir étaient vraiment
assez extraordinaire mais chacune dans
leur registre et tu avais la salle disco
années 80 et puis la salle hyper moderne
avec les musiques tendances et après tu
peux naviguer entre les deux quoi les
deux sont hyper passer on vient de voir
deux parties bon une qu'on a pas
vraiment vu en direct parce qu'on a
plutôt regardé mvl mais la partie de
Magnus et Vincent Kemer Vincent Kemer
c'est hyper bon et elle est géniale la
partie et l'autre partie qu'on a vu
aussi honnêtement j'ai pas j'ai pas de
préférence réelle pour moi les deux
parties font font sont monstrueuses font
partie de la catégorie de jeu beau jeu
dans des registres très différents et on
a de la chance de voir ça c'est vraiment
extraordinaire
on change de discours
pour vous dire la vérité à ce que je
fais je suis en train de
m'écrire moi j'ai un petit papier à côté
de moi où je me mets des parties que je
veux regarder plus tard et très sûrement
d'ailleurs allez commenter
sur Youtube vous voyez en toi comme ça
on a envie de partager tout ça donc
écoutez
à chaque à chaque tournoi donc au moment
checker rapidement souvent
là il a plusieurs parties du tournoi qui
sont qui sont qui sont vraiment
monstrueuses on pourra on pourra
reparler après mais déjà il a joué
contre il a des parties qui sont
monstrueuses c'était la partie contre
vente forest qui était pas mal déjà
complètement génial moi la partie
d'ailleurs je vais me la marquer aussi
mais la partie de dubaf m'intéresse tu
vois théoriquement parlant tu vois parce
que j'ai envie de voir est-ce que c'est
d'ailleurs un système bien sûr en plus
hyper plein le système joué par par
guéri et sur un début rétier avec
l'ordre de coups qu'il a joué d'ailleurs
guéri c'est difficile de trouver des
parties un peu enlevées un peu rigolotes
et là c'est exactement ce qu'a réussi à
faire du bas une partie rigolote qu'il
gagne et qui a l'air d'être tout à fait
correct puisque c'est jouer à au niveau
alimentaire donc c'est
tout
le monde et je te laisse y répondre je
peux rien faire là pour toi
donc bon c'est c'est des gens qui se
chambre se chambre mais qui se respecte
ah oui complètement
par là avec avec
des profils proches pour moi avec avec
Charlie qui a choisi une carrière trop
loin des échecs mais sinon on est
certain que
j'ai pas vu on peut aller voir ce qui
s'est passé
c'est un petit peu le blé tu vois c'est
un petit peu le jeu l'écran un problème
entre mamelia Rohff juste et son
adversaire je sais pas ce qui s'est
passé c'est une triple répétition mais
ah oui donc ça a été en tout cas ma mère
je sais pas ce qui s'est passé mais n'a
pas l'air très très satisfait est-ce que
c'est un coup illégal est-ce que c'est
juste pour savoir comme c'est du direct
on va aller voir
il fait l'amour Mohamed on va aller voir
je vais finir cette partie de dames de
plus à un moment mais est-ce que c'était
si clair
ah oui Jules en fait c'était pas son
temps le bon temps qui était indiqué je
crois qu'il avait oublié sa partie mais
non visiblement il a été sérieux mais
bon juste le temps
hyper difficile et puis la partie est
complètement folle là aussi on a une
partie très déséquilibrée on y comprend
pas grand-chose le roi de Julian 8 il y
a un petit euh
vous voyez que le roi de Jules qui est
parti hein du château parce qu'il avait
peur de se faire attaquer
[Musique]
visiblement en G7 et même sur le pion ça
peut aussi il faut être tout F4 qui peut
attaquer deux fois l'option F7 donc il
est parti un peu avec son roi je pense
qu'il voulait ramener son roi par ici
et c'est pas passé comme comme il le
voulait avec
ours C4 là
qui va tomber là-dessus de donner la
dame et malheureusement ben ça
fait trop dur là les blancs c'est fini
une pièce pour gagner plus facilement se
simplifier la vie oui au final vous
voyez que là matériellement j'ai quand
même deux pièces pour la dame et que
comme le roi il est un petit peu en
réseau il peut y avoir des petites
complications
la deuxième tour
et c'est trop dur en les pions sont
beaucoup trop forts
j'ai échec celui de 23 mois
non plus donc
qui est toujours en partie on a quand
même fait peur
il y a eu une répétition en fait ouais
ils ont vérifié parce que du coup
nakafe il a une dame d'avance bon pour
tout cavalier il y a quand même un pion
de plus le pion F qui est passé c'est
dangereux c'est mais bon les blancs sont
mieux sont même gagnants sûrement mais
en pratique c'est pas si simple
exactement en fait ce qui s'est passé
c'est que du coup
répéter trois fois l'imposition sans
faire exprès
ils ont fait nul et gagner du temps si
vous voulez pour bien comprendre ce qui
s'est passé et l'autre avec
10 secondes à chaque cours en fait du
coup il a joué vite pour essayer de
gagner du temps sur ça mais au final du
coup
il a répété des fois ça arrive pas
compte qu'on répète trois fois la
position et on pense faire deux fois etc
et après on change mais il a dû faire
trois fois sans en rendre compte parce
que tu es pas content de faire nul ce
qui se comprend avec une dame d'avance
mais ben écoute sa faute ça fait mal ça
du rapide non la joie du rapide c'est ça
alors on a une partie ici qui peut être
intéressant pour le tournoi c'est
toujours Artémis avec les Blancs contre
heregasi un gaze dit qu'il faut qu'il la
tienne c'est pas évident de tenir
c'est la galère de jouer ça
je vais voir sur internet
et il y en aka qui doit essayer de
gagner aussi une position qui est
difficile à gagner mais il a des petites
chances
d'embrouille
ma cadence donc il y a un rajoutant de
10 secondes parcours à chaque fois c'est
15 + 10 la cadence sur la cadence
traditionnelle de rapide du 15 + 10
donc là c'est chaud parce que cette
position vous voyez en fait
les blancs
pour essayer après de ramener le pion
Adam donc c'est un pion a certes mais
d'un autre côté le renard est tellement
loin qu'on pourra faire une barrière
pour empêcher le roi de passer et bien
sûr les Noirs veulent pas changer la
main donc ils veulent garder donc ça
c'est une position qui est censée être
nulle théorique Kevin mais après ce qui
est pratique c'est dur parce que tu peux
pas te tromper avec les Noirs
généralement un petit conseil pour les
gens qui auraient ce type de finale et
là il me semble que le meilleur moyen de
défendre de mettre son roi sur un sur un
courant sur un sur un bord
ouais côté opposé à la promotion je
pense
aller en géant naturellement mais bon
on va choisir le composé donc roi C3
il va essayer d'éviter
à la fois les échecs là
s'organiser
alors qu'on voit que neiman est en train
de sa partie là trois tours contre roi
fou donc
et
la répète involontaire c'est vrai que
c'est pas
ça va jouer longtemps
très clairement
c'est parti elle va jouer parce que là
clairement c'est une là elle est
peut-être une théorique mais en pratique
c'est très très dur donc il y a quand
même beaucoup de chance voilà
franchement ici comment tu vas durer toi
les chances des blancs de gagner un
pourcentage
je pense qu'il va gagner artémia je suis
obligé de penser ça non blague à part
oui je pense que la position est dure
pour les Noirs
je dirais c'est plus que 55 ans en règle
générale mais
je sens Artémis assez à l'aise
particulièrement dans cette cadence là
je trouve que c'est en défaveur des
Noirs qu'il y a les deux joueurs seront
à une autre les Blancs ne risquent rien
ils vont pas donner leur pion d'un coup
j'espère que je vais pas pouvoir
certains meuf en disant ça mais c'est
assez peu probable par contre un échec
malencontreux un échange de dames tu
vois Adam ceci c'est pas si facile que
ça à jouer maintenant je peux encore
pousser mon pion je peux faire d'un mode
de échec et A6 etc etc
en fait tu as la position est nulle mais
en pratique c'est tellement difficile en
plus avec peu de temps à la pendule que
au final on est obligé
je le voyais mieux près de son pion
quand même tu vois dans ces positions
j'ai du mal à il a le droit un peu coupé
c'est plutôt bien ingénieux de la dame
C6 après il reste 23 secondes certes
mais il y a quand même 10 secondes
parcours donc
c'est pas non plus
dur pour les deux joueurs cette position
mais il y a un petit peu de progression
quand même voilà moi je suis allé en C4
B4 mais
attention l'échange de Damas bien sûr à
un moment s'il survient maintenant
peut-être 3
on peut tout tester avec les Blancs si
vous voulez alors que les noirs n'ont
pas ces tests là il faut qu'il soit sûr
de
la roi des quatre peut-être
voilà et là il y a beaucoup de
possibilités d'échanges donc là les
Noirs vont
être obligé de
faire Dame des un échec par exemple ou
de surtout pas de revenir en C6 parce
qu'il y a Dame des cinq et chaque des
blancs qui gagnerait la partie donc
d'amener un seul coup normal et
maintenant je vais repartir avec mon roi
peut-être accompagné mon pion c'est dur
hein je sais pas trop comment me
débrouiller pour faire nul
en plus il y a eu le coup à 5 qui a été
joué le quoi 5 qui a été joué au 95e
coups du coup vous savez la règle des 50
pouces en prise nous vendu il y avait
plus d'échec là attends si là il y avait
chacun
ici pour empêcher l'échec on peut jouer
de dame là bouger le roi
ça à chaque fois on peut faire beaucoup
de tests
à pousser tu vois c'est toujours un peu
la galère pour faire ça aussi exactement
de
d'empêcher les échecs je pense
bien la règle des 50 coups on vous la
rappelez maintenant sans prise ni
poussée de pion sauf que dans une finale
de dames comme ça dès que je pousse mon
pion d'une case je repars pour la règle
des 50 coups si vous voulez la nuit ne
peut pas
c'est vraiment le pire qu'un pour les
gaze ici
elle a toujours existé cette règle en
tout cas depuis qu'on joue aux échecs
avec stouf elle existe cette règle des
50 coups mais historiquement parlant tu
me poses une belle colle
il y a eu ces quatre jouer
il peut jouer à 6 hein
cette cette histoire
ça me dit quelque chose dans le coin
opposé très loin
comment on continue comme ça
j'aimerais pas être à la place des Noirs
tu sais que tu as de grandes chances de
perdre
donc toujours contre
Serge vous pouvez regarder on vous
montrera ma position de pâte on doit
être à la recherche du pâtes c'est une
technique classique
on se met dans le coin opposé à la
couleur de notre fou
c'est comme là aussi en ce moment
composé
au point de verre
mais ça joue vous voyez là ils sont pas
là pour rigoler les joueurs
et attention plus d'échec
contre échec voilà le contre échec de
stuff là
donc moi bouge pas je vais être obligé
de jouer un coup de dames dans le désert
à 6 il est parti on va à 4
et donc là on peut peut-être penser du
coup
je suis sûr de pouvoir faire à 7 après
une fois que j'ai fait à 7 c'est déjà là
que il y aura des difficultés c'est
quelque chose comme ça
j'aimerais pas être
déstabiliser la défense parce que on
voit que la jauge ne bouge pas donc ça
veut dire que ce n'est pas gagnant vous
voyez mais on n'a pas envie de la jouer
à la place des regga easy qui à chaque
fois une vingtaine de secondes pour
jouer qui à la fois pas beaucoup mais
beaucoup pour lui
bon on se met dans le coin opposé donc
on se met pas exactement sur la case de
la couleur de la case de promo à chaque
fois il laisse en fait
régalé se tromper parce que là il
autorise pas d'échec il est ton réseau
aucun échec
des noirs et du coup il laisse vraiment
[Musique]
de pousser à ça je pense peut-être
centraliser la dame pour avoir un
maximum de contrôle des coûts d'échec je
sais pas ce que tu en penses tout
j'essaie des choses mais je verrai bien
damger cette pour commencer et puis
après on travaille on travaille la
position de la dame à l'aide de quelques
coups des chats et au bon moment on fera
à 7
très bien maintenant
en escalier madame
jusqu'à trouver une case plus centrale
plus de contrôle des échecs futurs de
l'adversaire
en tout cas on va avoir une partie 150
coups vraisemblablement même plus
le pion à 6 a été joué au 111e coup là
ils sont au 114 donc autant vous dire
qu'il y a encore beaucoup de coups à
faire
puis depuis on peut faire encore que
deux cases parce qu'une fois qu'il en a
8 c'est abondant
donc on a encore quasiment 100 coups
autorisé
donc du coup on pourra pas en mise à
jour des scores que mvl a fait match nul
donc il va être à 6 sur 10
Jules Moussa défaite à 4 et demi sur 10
et Sébastien Mazet a lui aussi perdu 5
et demi sur 10 il avait forte à faire
face à Richard importe on peut
maintenant dire que nos joueurs français
vont se diriger tranquillement vers le
beat
à part Seb mon gagnant ces deux
dernières parties il pourra ouais pour
encore jouer un gros joueur quoi donc il
doit viser cela mais on sait que les
ambitions de Jules et de Maxime va chez
Lagrave était de remporter ou de figurer
dans le top 10 tout au moins pour pour
aller au combat et là ils ont hypothéqué
leur chance donc maintenant c'est le
Blitz à fond à fond
à penser à cela en fait là il faut
commencer à pousser un peu les pions
mais tu vois j'ai du mal dès que je veux
vraiment pousser il y a plein d'échecs
qui arrivent et
en plus quand A7 c'est pas sûr que tu
gagnes du tout ça gagne pas d'ailleurs
mais
du coup il préfère épuiser un peu le
défenseur
et essayer de trouver une circonstance
favorable
il va essayer de casser le moral un
petit peu
il défend aussi flottant régalizi à ce
moment là
cette finale
si on pense à ça nul il faut laisser le
pion arriver à 7 dans d'autres pour
pouvoir après coller des échecs
intempestifs
qui sont sur eux qui est pas mal c'est
pas faux Cyril que Maxime faisait
peut-être plus le Blitz que le rapide
mais bon quand même pour un joueur de ce
niveau là tu peux pas t'empêcher de
penser
que tu peux jouer quelque chose dans le
rapide donc c'est comme une idée
déception après ça c'est un produit
moi je pense clairement qu'il était
pour les deux mais quand il a vu que tu
commença à pas bien jouer il s'est dit
bon de toute façon
là depuis depuis hier déjà c'est sûr que
qu'il a plus d'espoir à remplir
à 8 et ça change rien quoi après faut
juste que
replacer le roi il a fait avant un truc
comme ça
pas évident comme défense en tout cas ce
qui fait
tout faut garder une petite réserve de
temps il a bien fait je trouve à ryoun
depuis le départ
réserve de temps elle est limitée vous
avez bien compris mais si on peut éviter
de jouer les coups une seconde deux
secondes trois secondes donc sur échec
il y a la dame de 8 couvert il se fait
contrer chacun là ça perdrait parce
qu'après il change d’âme on apprend je
fais de nouvelles dames donc je ne peux
pas faire à chaque sur la 8e rangée
c'est important
je pense qu'il va jouer ça
veut dire qu'on arrive à chaque fois à
faire à cette
[Musique]
je pense qu'il va jouer ça et plus
précis ce qu'il a joué je sais plus
pourquoi mais
j'aurais toujours pas échec sur le
compte il faut peut-être faire croire
j'ai un à ce moment-là
il va bouger le roi voilà
pour s'enlever un peu des échecs de la
vie à manger
c'est le manchot c'est le moment
critique ici pas se tromper il faut
qu'ils se stéréotype une défense et même
si la jauge indique que c'est l'une ça
fout la presse
retourne ici ben tu avances pas s'il y a
dame revient en B7 dame
pour mettre sa dame et
Artémis pour enlever sa dame et sortir
son roi au moins qu'une dame assez
centralisée pour essayer de contrer son
adversaire
en rapide comme ça que la pression je
trouve ça ouvre de toute façon au final
mais comment on fait c'est perdu non
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on fait là
[Musique]
il a perdu direct
terminé
mais comme ça ils peuvent continuer les
échecs
pour faire nul même dans les mains d'un
très jeune joueur
même les tests de tout je me la joue
en plus c'est ça
donc on a vu que c'était le composé on a
compris cette finale grâce à
airigaziz mais c'est plutôt aux dépens
des registres qui s'est trompé
est-ce que est-ce qu'on pouvait tenir
réellement c'est dur
non mais ça doit être nul mais tu sais
forcer enfin tu vois
la galère quoi très très dangereux cette
position
tu défends défends défends et puis tu
finis par gaffer quoi c'est c'est humain
a fait ce qu'il fallait si vous voulez
il a mis du temps pour ce champion à 7
parce qu'il savait qu'un jour ou l'autre
il pourrait le pousser en A7 donc il a
épuisé un peu le défenseur et au moment
où Wario
avait tenu avec l'option A6 etc vous
savez ce qu'il fallait à 7 et là c'est
le moment critique il avait pas beaucoup
de temps il a perdu tout de suite
[Musique]
en tout cas en tout cas belle
démonstration d'artemief et ici très
très beau joueur
mais qui sera dangereux c'est ça mais du
coup il perd cette partie qui ça demande
difficulté pour le sprint final
à son entrée stuff à plus de 200700
artemief avec que je fais quelque chose
d'assez hallucinant il avait enchaîné la
victoire au chocolat d'Europe et la
victoire à Gibraltar qui est en moins
d'un mois une performance extraordinaire
quoi gagner deux des plus forts tournois
on va dire format Open qui existe
c'était
contre biomakine
bon il y aura sans doute une belle nulle
donc pour moi qui n'a gardé une réserve
de temps suffisante c'est nul il y a pas
grand chose à faire juste à attendre
avec le roi blanc n'a pas de cash si
vous voulez et les deux pions sont
coincés par le roi épiderme
un bon coup je trouve
que c'est final là ne gagne jamais parce
que si le roi bouge ben je prends un
pion c'est c'est nul direct et si la
tour bouge j'ai pas un coup tu fais
échec aura bouge je prends le pion et
c'est la fenêtre finale file d'or que
tout le monde connaît et c'est nul
tranquille donc G6 normalement c'est le
coup du professionnel
qui va permettre de faire nul direct et
pas se prendre la tête je pense c'est
vous qui va être vieux par burger ça m'a
l'air ça m'a l'air tout à fait
[Musique]
très belle remarque de Charlie en tout
cas
en deuxième qui a marqué Bruno
en troisième j'ai marqué Ivic et en
quatrième tu es marqué en route
[Rires]
je pensais que j'avais un Bolton et
bourmaking ça va
tu as mis carcennes
malheureusement les petits jeunes sont
en forme
et du coup si on fait un petit point
classement il est pas à jour encore
surescom parce que la partie je vois
encore celle là je vois encore
malheureusement je peux pas vous le
montrer il y a une nul il y a eu le G6
ou pas il y a eu G6 pose tout qui fait
nul en fait direct parce qu'on prend ça
et là c'est fini d'or il l'ont ils l'ont
même pas joué ok du coup dans un instant
on va recevoir enfin on va voir en fait
la mise à jour du du
classement
8 points et demi qui a un point d'avance
sur sur deux bof AppStore qui est là
hein Artémis ici donc on a quand même un
4 joueurs à 7h30 donc 45 il peut encore
se faire attraper
s'il perdait contre un siège voir là
bien sûr bien sûr ça reste ouvert mais
quand même un point d'avance on sait
qu'il sera
trois rondes avant la fin on sait qu'il
sera sûrement sur le podium voilà pas
sûr il y a pas de certitude mais il a
vraiment pris une option il a pris une
option
avec 6 et demi avec deux points de la
carte Z et un point derrière
du monde
c'est donc du coup
faire le come-back
voilà qui qui a 7 points qui ont combien
de mois on les voit pas du tout je sais
pas ce qu'ils font
4e et qui est troisième en ce moment
donc je veux que toi c'est vrai mais bon
tu es quand même pas mauvais par contre
Naka Naka il est 36e je pense qu'il sera
pas un podium c'est clair
où es-tu possible
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé pour Yann
Christophe
il a pas un bon de partage apparemment
mais il est en busqué il est embusqué il
est bien plus que quand même il est bien
embusqué
mais on va voir en tout cas ce qui se
passe danser
dans ce championnat alors est-ce que
c'est comme mamie
mise à jour et ça n'a pas encore été mis
à jour
pas été mis à jour donc je peux pas vous
montrer le classement
ce que je propose c'est qu'on croise un
petit pause de 5 minutes et à la reprise
du enfin de la pause et ben je vous
montre directement le le
classement ainsi que les appareils etc
enfin un point d'ici 5 minutes super on
fait comme ça souffle un petit café
c'est reparti quoi ça marche à tout de
suite allez à tout de suite à tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes de retour avec Kevin du
coup
deuxième ronde de la journée ça veut
dire que c'est la 11e ronde du tournoi
sur 13 rondes évidemment c'est ça je
suis trompé de scène de scène pardon pas
de chaîne avant avant dernière ronde de
ce championnat du monde de rapide avec
un Magnus Carlsen qui a un point
d'avance seul en tête avec 8 et demi
vous avez promis les résultats mais
malheureusement c'est comme me fait
mentir ils n'ont pas mis à jour donc je
vous incarne une surprise avec le
classement qui apparaît devant vous je
l'ai fait moi-même à la main
merci à toi donc voilà vous avez un
classement qui est là sous vos yeux on
voit 45,8
et Carona à 7,5
c'est top là
c'est génial la technique
donc ça c'est pour pour les résultats de
la ronde est-ce que j'ai les appareils
mangent regarde à côté sur mon chasse
reset parce que tu sanchoscom ça
malheureusement pas encore été mis à
peine salut poignard salut tous ceux qui
nous ont rejoints salut à tous et on
voit d'ailleurs les appareils
les apparisants on a un Carl Seine qui
joue avec les Noirs contre artemiev et
ça c'est les gars la partie qu'il faut
suivre qu'on fasse suivre là je pense
pour cette d'ailleurs parce qu'il faut
le battre maintenant avec les Blancs
donc Artémis il a une cartouche il faut
y aller il y a pas le choix et ça par
rapport au classement je peux je peux
vous remettre le classement pendant que
je vous demande au parement regardez
apparemment attendez je vais revenir sur
sur le classement
on a ici je vous redis on a 47 points du
coup Artémis blanc qui a 7,5
a vraiment
une grosse carte à jouer ici contrôle
Carcassonne
ensuite on a gagné il a presque bloqué
le tournoi c'est-à-dire que après avec
nul blanc il aurait pris quasiment gagné
je pense donc c'est ça donc bon
en tout cas ça sera prêt sera à la
rencontre on a deux bof blanc contre
Caravana et ensuite on a vite dit contre
notre
qui est là qui est là près il attend
l'erreur de carcène pour revenir
à sa hauteur et pour aussi bien se
placer on a aussi la caméra qui est
contre nepo ça aussi à une partie
intéressante avec enjeu parce que du
coup les genres peuvent sur place pour
le podium rapidement avant les deux
donne à rondes
et bien sûr
et demi vous voyez il y a énormément de
joueurs à 6 et demi qu'on a Douda par
exemple
mais beaucoup de monde on a ericasique
du condo gritchouc ça c'est aussi un une
affiche vraiment intéressante pas de bol
comme apparemment pour ceux qui ont 6 et
demi qui sont confrontés à un adversité
très très forte parce que c'est cette
nuit on a quand même envoyé on a on a
rapport on a dudat en acryluk média
Rohff on a dit
ça c'est vraiment les meilleurs joueurs
du groupe et après il y a beaucoup de
joueurs qui ont entre 2006 2007
mais les meilleurs argent en plus on a
aussi à 6 points en Nakamura on a mvl on
a si Penko on a beaucoup beaucoup de
monde du coup assez point aussi donc
voilà en tout cas on va suivre en
priorité là la partie table 1 artemief
blanc contre Carlson parce que au final
les gars on joue quand même pour le
titre champion du monde non c'est parti
et c'est une partie qui est très
importante wartemf peut clairement
mettre la pression un quart de scène
essayer de le sortir
on s'intéresse moins moins déjà c'est
une demande de Chaska mais bien sûr le
tournoi est mixte le tournoi qui
desserne le titre de champion CMX donc
du coup bon
on continue là-dessus et c'est vrai que
bah on peut pas faire les deux
véritablement vous voyez qu'il y a déjà
beaucoup de parties à surveiller avec
avec stouf on fait au mieux et n'hésitez
pas par contre à demander on a vu que
Charlie nous a fait une super remarque à
la ronde précédente concernant la partie
entre entre guéri et doubaf donc si vous
voyez vraiment une grosse partie
n'hésitez pas à nous faire faire un
petit détour par celle-ci on a suivi les
joueurs français là ils sont vraiment
loin dans le classement donc on va on va
être moins Chauvin que d'habitude et on
va s'intéresser au titre véritablement
maintenant le sprint au final est lancé
c'est le money time donc la grosse
partie entre Artémis et Carcen à prévoir
est-ce que Artemia va aller le chercher
Carlsen où est-ce qu'il va essayer de
bloquer les chiquer et faire nul pour
cette surplace dans une course gamme où
est-ce qu'il va prendre les risques pour
devenir champion du monde de rapide à la
suite que je pense qu'il va juste partir
et voir un peu ce qui se passe selon
selon les choix de Carson aussi je pense
pas que c'est un joueur qui va se
suicider
Artémis il va pas faire all-in
complètement mais il va quand même
essayer de de la partie j'espère
en retard n'est pas qui s'installe entre
Kemer est déjà prêt
n'est pas de toute façon on sait que il
aime mettre la pression donc même arrivé
en retard pour lui c'est pas trop gênant
pour d'autres joueurs ça le serait plus
un joueur qui est toujours bien au temps
et on a le droit à une Bogo indienne
sur la bécasse naturelle en C3 mais faut
prendre les deux c'est déjà assez
marginal à 5 de 7 plus fréquents
C5 aussi mais faut prendre des deux
je pense qu'il veut essayer peut-être je
sais pas ce que tu en penses mais car
c'est il a un point d'avance je pense
qu'il a déjà fait le job et là il veut
juste essayer avec les noirs de ne pas
perdre cette partie il va faire nul noir
poussette blanche nul noir poussette
blanche ça serait logique en tout cas je
trouve bien vu Bienvenue dans le parler
poussette blanche on va dire que il va
jouer l'ouverture voir ce que ça donne
de toute façon en jouant normalement
avec les Blancs
il va pousser son adversaire sans
prendre de et voir comment l'adversaire
joue et s'adapter en fonction de cela on
a vu que il a écrasé
avec une grande classe Vincent Kemer
dans la ronde précédente et puis il
avait fait une poussette blanche
infructueuse contre du boeuf parce que
dubaf était très très bien préparé
théoriquement et a aussi très bien joué
et la bloquer mais s'il continue comme
ça en restant solide avec les Noirs il
ne peut rien lui arriver
c'est ça
c'est ça donc du coup voilà bon c'est
une partie intéressante ou car ça n'a
pas le droit à l'erreur je vous rappelle
que Carsens il perd cette partie et ben
le tournoi est courtois relancer Artémis
reviendrait sur Carcassonne aussi les
joueurs qui sont en embuscade comme on a
vu à Boston offre on a vu aussi du bof
qui pouvait aussi revenir sur
Carcassonne
et d'ailleurs même une une partie nul
pour eux aussi le mettre aussi en
difficulté parce que si doivent gagner
et pour revenir quasiment à sa hauteur
en tout cas derrière les ports suivants
doivent enchaîner les victoires pour
essayer de revenir sur lui donc c'est
quand même pas évident mais voilà car
c'est déjà ici avec les noirs pendant
plus qui fasse au lit non il faut juste
qu'ils gère son tournoi et qui joue
solide et qui voit un peu ce qui se
passe derrière les vrais aussi que que
le fait de faire un nul va ça ralenti
aussi artemief qui restera à un point
derrière lui
avec deux rondes donc du coup voilà
certains meuf veut vraiment gagner mais
vraiment le champion du monde et bah il
faut qu'il faut qu'il prenne des risques
et du coup pas forcément là pour ça
donc il essaie de bloquer bloquer les
chiquer on voit il allait changer une
pièce mineure il avait concédé le centre
et maintenant il fait ses 5 pour
récupérer le centre on voit tout de même
que même s'il arrive à échanger le pion
c'est ça qu'on le pion des 4
mécaniquement dans cette position
Artémis va avoir une petite avance de
développement et du coup il y a pas
grand risque avec les Blancs maintenant
de là à gagner cette position ça va être
difficile mais il peut jouer sans
pression là pour l'instant Artémis il a
quelques coups pour essayer de prendre
un petit plus je pense par contre qu'il
connaît beaucoup moins bien que la
position que Magnus puisqu'on a dit le
choix de Magnus et marginal et il n'est
pas facile dans une cadence aussi rapide
de trouver la très bonne ligne qui va
faire
prendre l'avantage tout simplement
Artémis
3 minutes au bout de 9 coups alors que
alors que que Carcen et ben il est monté
à 16 minutes donc vous savez qu'on
commence à on commence à 15 minutes et
et chaque coup on gagne 10 secondes donc
là 45 qui a déjà réussi à gagner
à la pendue une minute personne qui
avait tout tempo pour l'instant cette
partie
que la caméra est sur un imam donc je
pense pas que ce soit ce soit ce que
personne voudrait on va essayer de
changer on va revenir sur
sur la cam de caracène
si on confondait Carlson et
énigme
et une des personnalités du monde
échiquier donc c'est comme ça
c'est moche mais c'est quand même le
grand classique
donc c'est prendre un 4 là de points à
manger ce qu'on joue pour le pion isolé
est-ce qu'on met le Cavaillon en D4
parce que moi je la dame pour la place
après faire l'attaque
plusieurs plusieurs possibilités
quand même le contenu normal Kevin c'est
plutôt cavaler prendre des cadres j'ai
envie de dire mais on pourrait s'exposer
alors je sais pas si du coup comme ça
[ __ ] pouvait être possible pour sortir
le fou une des cartes est rigolo pour le
côté donc normalement donc on évite le
pion isolé mais ça existe pour avoir un
très bon développement de pièces la eD4
fait sens mais il y a une pièce mineure
d'échanger c'est à dire pourquoi je dis
que eux prend des cartes fait sens parce
qu'on a des seins qui semblent facilités
en même temps il y aura peut-être tour
D8 qui qui est une histoire
mais eux prend des cartes pour gagner
des équilibrer la position me semble
intéressant normalement le fait pas
quand il y a une pièce mineure
d'échanger comme j'ai des 5 dans la
foulée pourquoi pas ça se regarde
généralement quand vous avez un pion
isolé il faut garder les pièces et pas
échanger il faut attaquer et comme j'ai
déjà changé une pièce bah le pion isolé
est pas forcément une bonne une bonne
nouvelle c'est ça donc Kamel prends des
cartes donc là on s'expose comme à Dieu
5 et un développement assez rapide donc
qui est aussi très bien et très solide
c'est une position c'est souple
structurellement comme ça il garde
l'option proposée par stouf et en même
temps on a cavalé ces 6 E5 a plus de
choses à surveiller côté blanc on
pourrait voir assez rapidement d'un mode
de tout rêve D1 et et une position assez
égale parce que j'ai perdu 5 minutes la
position qui en résulte est de plus en
plus
hermétique alors juste pour voir qui est
ici savant n'était pas trop possible à
cause de la structure de pions qui
serait immonde rien à voir entre les
deux ça serait presque foutu vous pouvez
vous c'est quasiment la même idée par
contre on n'a pas la même réalisation et
vous voyez que l'exemple de stouf est
très pédagogique parce que là vous venez
de faire une une énorme Betty
stratégique ce que vous offrez une cible
pour toute la partie donc ça c'est
vraiment
à montrer au jour amateur par contre
faut des 7 c'est l'urgence de la
position je développe le fousser vite et
le cavalier B8
un peu enfermé votre va se retrouver
très actif et
du coup bah les pièces sont échangés les
Noirs joue une position solide il va
juste avoir je pense que il joue pour
l'égalité c'est parti ton rêve D1 kssi
c'est kdb5 pour essayer de faire un
petit quelque chose avec un cavalier en
D6 mais c'est peut-être pas suffisant
pour prendre la colonne et peut-être
qu'il peut jouer assis ici assis
peut-être était très fort aussi tu vois
il y a les deux qui
qui empêche cavaler intéressante et la
cavalier Cécile derrière et je peux dire
que celle là pour la gagner ça va être
ça va être pénible
à moi qui ai dû les aider plus tard avec
du cavalier à 4 pour venir à un point de
6 mais
il y a toujours la fourchette avec B5
donc du coup
pour l'instant dans tous les cas ici
après faut dire
donc j'espère qu'il la connaît
un peu jusque là tu vois il a gagné 49
secondes en 10 coups ça fait qu'il a
gagné
en moyenne tu vois quasiment
je sais pas si mon parc ou quoi en tout
cas les coups noirs se jouent en plus
assez facilement donc c'est vraiment
cool quoi pour lui il a bien réussi son
ouverture je pense qu'il va
ça pourrait être une le rapide
ça pourrait être très rigolote
montfer nul c'est pas un peu déconnant
il peut après il est quand même bien
placé dans le tournoi il peut après
essayer de prendre un risque pour un
jour un peu moins fort et essayer de
viser la deuxième place voir la
troisième mais si bacardson et ben il
peut être champion du monde après
Carlson est dans ce tournoi il est
vraiment dans une forme olympique oui
parce que même si bacalsen il est pas
encore champion du monde en plus
gagner des parties derrière même en plus
au départage il faudrait encore battre
enfin bon
derrière ça gagne aussi parce que s'il
annule derrière dans les matchs des
tables 2 et 3 bah
il n'y aura pas d'avancé significative
donc c'est vraiment une il a vraiment
pris une grosse option
Magnus
un point d'avance à trois rondes de la
fin
c'est énorme
après 11 CROUS il a le double du temps
de son adversaire et parfois on dit OUI
Magnus il est pas si bien préparé
théoriquement c'était un des un des
grands discours de keryakin qui n'est
pas présent dans ce tournoi car il y a
Kim qui est exceptionnellement bien
préparé dans les ouvertures mais on peut
considérer quand même que Magnus est un
des meilleurs théoriciens au monde et
point voilà
c'est clair il est très très complet
Magnus
c'est difficile de trouver un défaut en
fait à Magnus je sais pas alors cette
Mazet il joue en 2370 un maître fidèle
tout à l'heure oui parce que quand il
perd une partie Seb il se retrouve à
jouer faible et comme il a un hello par
rapport à au tournoi qui n'est pas très
fort bah il se retrouve soit jouer voilà
Richard rapporte la partie précédente un
gros costaud et après quand elle perd
BIM un faible qui lui permettra
peut-être de revenir pour les deux
dernières rondes ou la dernière ronde
est retapé un des gros clients du
tournoi c'est tout le mal qu'on lui
souhaite
il y a une question pour toi là
des kenyo carpov qui est revenu
alors
bon vous savez j'ai lancé une plateforme
mais la première si tu veux vidéo
série ou pas de vidéo comme on veut je
l'ai fait sur la carrocane que je n'ai
moi même assez peu joué mais j'aime bien
ces variantes françaises carrocane pour
démarrer je trouve que ces ouvertures
qu'on peut garder sur le long terme
c'est tout et qui évite d'aller sur E4 5
ou 4c5 qui sont pour moi des coûts qui
sont excellents mais très très
difficiles à aborder parce que très
massif en terme de de théorie en terme
d'arborescence stouf donc du coup dans
dans cette variante car aucun sur KD2 ou
cavalier C3 on prend le 4 et on fait
cavalier F6 derrière la vente moderne
parce que j'estime que c'est moins de
temps de travail
et
sur la variante d'avance je fais ces 5
rapides je pense que c'est ça que tu
voulais dire ce que pour la variante
d'échange vu qu'il y a eu panda c'est
prendre il n'y a pas de ces 5 rapides
donc je pense que c'était sur la ronde
d'avance que tu voulais me m'entendre
peigne nos carpes et oui le 3 c'est 5
que j'aime beaucoup puisque le Trois
Fois F5 est un peu plus joué au niveau
mais laisse beaucoup beaucoup de
systèmes blancs donc l'idée en fait
c'est de proposer quelque chose qui est
fiable sur le long terme mais qui est
moins coûteux en termes de temps voilà
temps de travail pour vous les joueurs
amateurs voilà comment je construis les
répertoires d'ouverture pour mes élèves
je veux que ce soit bon sur le long
terme et pas trop coûteux en terme de
temps de travail parce que je sais que
nous avec tout on fait des échecs tout
le temps tout le temps tout le temps et
depuis toujours quasiment ce qui n'est
pas le cas de tous les joueurs amateurs
donc c'est important de trouver des
bonnes ouvertures des ouvertures
adaptées
à votre style à votre niveau et que vous
pouvez garder pour longtemps voilà voilà
le petit point le petit point carreau
canne pegnocarpov et pour revenir à
cette partie on s'ennuie en fait on
s'ennuie petit pressing évidemment du
fleuve 3 contre l'option B7 mais on va
pouvoir le gérer assez facilement je
pense qu'il y a pas vraiment de problème
alors après de me prendre des cartes
qu'est-ce qu'on fait
est-ce qu'on peut même jouer E5
parce que 5 est jouable dans cette
position ce que je peux pas jouer un
coup plus solide parce que j'ai quand
même mon pion à cet en l'air donc je
peux pas faire tour ab8 que j'avais
envie de faire
est-ce que j'ai le droit de jouer de
Tours fd8
dans un verre d'eau
nul de bœuf
ça fait les affaires de Carl Seine en
cas de nul est-ce que
est-ce que c'est Yann qui va nous sauver
et une envolée
elle est assez intéressante allez quand
tu vois cette position que Kemer est un
peu maté rapidement tu vois il y a un
truc qui va arriver on va jeter un oeil
rapide en plus c'est un début assez
modeste qui lui a permis d'obtenir cette
position
hyper hyper rigolote
[Musique]
on sait que si j'étais à la technique se
trouve ça balbutie beaucoup plus donc on
te remercie déjà de t'occuper de
l'aspect technique j'ai quatre superbes
j'ai 4 franchement j'adore ce genre de
coupe en pousse de violence qui attend
parce que c'est créé un stuff
qu'on voit tous les jours donc là on
fait quatre parce que le cavalier voyez
il est excusez-moi
ou un foulard stuff
25 degrés donc
[Rires]
j'ai 4G 5 c'est l'idée clairement on
veut agresser on va attaquer on va pas
tu vois penser aussi sur le fait que le
centre il va il a un petit peu fixé pour
l'instant je n'ai pas bouger et
valoriser le fou B2 bravo très belle
explications
vous voyez il y a le cavalier en F5 qui
tape sur G7 le fou qui est qui est
bloqué là le pion G qui a qui avance
c'est ça alors en tout cas en pratique
là je prends le temps tous les jours
c'est une position que j'aime beaucoup
pour les blancs
j'ai 6 et là j'ai 5 prise je prends du
four alors je sais pas je bois du fou
ici en F6 et
puis bon ouvert c'est pas possible Caval
et bouge cavaillage 6 donc là
paire de fou c'est à dire qu'on a fait
un faux échec et mat qui nous permet de
gagner la paire de fou comme les cases
noires sont ouvertes c'est déjà de la
stratégie de haute volet pour Vincent
Kemer
le pion HS ils sont fous ils sont fous
complètement lui ce qu'il veut c'est
ouvrir la position ouvrir les deux fous
et jouer sur le cadre noir au long terme
donc
stratégiquement par Carlson dans la
partie précédente et là je trouve qu'il
est en train de faire la leçon i am
pomachi ça m'arrange pas parce que
j'avais dit n'est pas au deuxième de ce
tournoi mais honnêtement il est en train
de de le déglinguer franchement c'est
magnifique ce qu'il est en train de
faire la partie elle est vraiment elle
est vraiment très très jolie après il
faut terminer il faut H3
je trouve qui est très très intéressant
à mon avis puisque tu peux pas prendre
un schiste et ça fait mal dame j'ai
trois si tu manges ici je prends et tu
as la paire de fou tu me laisses du foie
H3 là là ça va être dur après dans cette
position quand même j'ai envie de garder
les dames tu vois quand je vois un truc
comme ça je me réflexe c'est pas sur un
G3
je comprends mais bon vu que maintenant
on a vu que les parties de haut niveau
ont gagné tellement facilement de la
paire de fou c'est un avantage des CIF
c'est plus trois clairement c'est pas à
ce niveau là on joue beaucoup moins pour
le check et mat ça c'est clair donc un
peu rare de faire mat on a vu un
contre-exemple avec la partie de de
guéri et de douboff qui a gagné du bof
brillamment mais c'est vrai que c'est
assez rigolo cette histoire par exemple
de de Sarine contre de boeufs si le
damage 5 très joli on a vu hier
parce qu'on voit ça dans toute leur
partie et maintenant on est pour matchi
peut quasiment plier les Gaules je pense
qu'il va perdre cette partie maintenant
là j'avais vu faut H3 qui gagne la
partie en un coup donc c'est bizarre
qu'il est joué j'ai pas pensé qu'il
pouvait
qu'il pouvait le jouer peut-être qu'il
veut juste jouer qu'on pense bien sûr
mais bon
il aurait pu manger là et se dire bah
juge finalement bien et je vais perdre
parce que je suis moins bien ce pion il
est très fort la part de fou et hyper
fort en ligne peut-être à toi Fd1 prix
C5 on peut pas éviter du coup c'est trop
dur quoi on va regarder parce que là du
coup F5 c'est pas un coup bien sûr il
faut prendre
sur le roi donc là il va pas une qualité
mais en mangeant la qualité et ben j'ai
mon roi qui est un peu affaibli sur case
blanche
et j'ai quand même manger un pion
peut-être
comme ça en fait mais le roi noir et
pire quoi avec les cases noires parce
que bien sûr
ils ont ils ont des ressources quand
même qui sont incroyables donc il veut
tout ranger 4
belle idée et sans doute pas suffisant
parce que faut pas rêver F3 j'ai perdu 3
avec voilà
H3 H3 et tour là c'est quand même assez
embêtant 134 même prix C5 c'est pas si
bête ici une position j'ai l'impression
ouais je crois que c'est pas donné tu
veux donner la date je voulais faire
prise B6 visiblement ça marche pas mais
on peut jouer un petit coup d'attente
tu as pas mangé directement alors F3 ça
me plaisait pas mais je pensais à un
truc du style je sais pas moi
par rapport à tout à l'heure même
celle-là maintenant que je mange là tu
vois c'est peut-être pas forcément tu
vois la même
tu m'as pris mon idée en mieux c'est ça
ce que vous voyez
moi je te pique et j'améliore c'est ce
que je fais c'est incroyable bravo et ça
va très bien en tout cas on se régale là
franchement direct il a pas mangé ses
cinq il a joué F3 et il laisse ça et
l'autre variante qu'on regardait enfin
je regardais là j'avais prévu tout rage
4 mais c'était son de pas suffisant
et puis c'est 5 va faire mal tout va
faire mal tout va faire mal terminé
on était en train de discuter mais
c'était logique F3 ça empêche de faire
ton projet 4 c'est avec gant tempo même
après
il n'y a pas assez ce que je suis en
train de regarder aussi qui va arriver
ça va être ça va être très très dur pour
nepo nepo qui a peur tout de suite
il a joué F3 assez vite c'est une
une variante simple on peut les voir
après la caméra je voulais mettre à la
caméra là je vais changer là est-ce que
en politique
on n'a pas le droit de faire le coup de
fil à un ami donc on est obligé de se
débrouiller tout seul on va faire
mais là vous avez la caméra sur sur
quelle heure et dépôt une époque il y a
pas l'air très content
n'est pas qui a pas d'arme au début il
peut
peut déjà plier les Gaules
je vais pas nos affaires encore moins de
mon côté parce que nepo deuxième mais
essouffe il a annoncé le niveau 3e du
tournoi et sans doute que là il va
hypothéquer ses chances de revenir parce
que maintenant c'est pareil des coups
comme tout recette qu'on va qu'on va
gagner très clairement
il va se défendre mais tu as prises là
ça me voulait peut-être pas longtemps
peut-être pas longtemps parce que après
je peux faire tout reprend c'est 5 de
dame 3 dans ma vie
en fait aussi mais même tout prendre ça
marche
ok le score qui a été mal mis alors on
va aller voir ce que moi
il a gagné pardon c'est moi qui qui sait
pas lire un score il y a marqué 01 il
avait les Noirs
c'est pas le plus nul des grands maîtres
quand même hein
2600 quand même mais il a dû lui mettre
une sacrée alors bon on peut aller voir
ce qu'il a fait c'était une une anglaise
du coup on va vous mettre du côté
de cette thématique
cavalier 2 un système carpov C6 D5 très
logique dans cette position là
complètement raté son ouverture c'est
pas très bien bien sûr
pas très bien il y a une position de
structure un peu française avec en fait
un développement un peu raté où les
Noirs plus d'espace c'est le fou B2 qui
est une mauvaise pièce un centre bloqué
pour mettre l'attaque à l'elroit
et là c'est les noirs qui vont partir
avec
comme on a vu la position finale on sait
que ça aboutit
ça sent mauvais ok
mais ça fait peur humainement vous le
voyez bien
bien sûr sur foie F1 j'ai cavalier F3
qui fait 15 ans
et il a toujours eu plus de temps que
son adversaire
je pense que comme il joue rien ils ont
joué relativement vite cette partie les
deux
en pratique ben parce que là cavalier F3
F2
abondant le roi
forcer et damage 3 et jolie ouais donc
là Maxime qui a gagné avec une belle une
belle dérouillée franchement
oui voilà il joue un petit contrats
parce qu'il sait que c'est terminé donc
voilà apparemment personne aurait gaffé
et ce serait le tournant du tournoi et
c'est pas c'est quoi rapidement avec 11
minutes contre une minute dans une
position où il exerçait un pressing ça
peut le faire tilter grâce à un peu ça
qui vient de me donner la partie en un
coup qu'est-ce qui se passe le 4
pourquoi ça
F4 qui attaque le cavalier ouh là là
on va revenir sur 45 on va revenir sur
carcène très très vite la caméra là
c'est trop hein c'est trop loin ça les
robinside et merci en tout cas Franky 80
pour pour le suivi non
venir il est beaucoup trop loin c'est
toi qui l'avais fait en premier Super
regarde
tellement c'est
il fait ça de temps en temps c'est
toujours la même mimi mais 11 minutes
contre une minute il vient de donner la
partie du rapide comment il a perdu la
pièce en fait il fait cavalier 4 pour
échanger les pièces mais à trop vouloir
échanger des pièces et ben il voulait
présenter en plus il voulait presser
peut-être en faisant 4 et jouer pour
quelque chose mais là vous voyez en
prise et le cavalier en fait noir était
venu que par la dame et après F4 et ben
je peux pas défendre le cavalier avec
Madame par une autre cas ici ma seule
cas c'est la F5 et après dans 95 j'ai 4
donc bien sûr mais d'un autre côté il
faut que il faut que la dame parte quoi
et donc là une fois que ça me parle ben
vu je mange le cavalier et j'ai gagné
quoi même Carlson qui est au-dessus du
lot il a le droit des rap des rappels à
l'ordre du jeu d'échec parce que là
c'est vraiment cela il avait 11 minutes
contre une minute 30 complètement
décontractes une position qui ne pouvait
pas perdre bah regardez la position qui
pouvait pas perdre il va la perdre tout
de suite maintenant tour à 8 tour B8 et
du gain du pion B6 et sans doute de
l'abandon de Magnus directement
complètement craqué
magnifique
ce que je viens de faire alors que on va
dire que a fait plutôt une mauvaise
partie parce qu'avec les blancs il a
rien obtenu
l'appartement c'était plutôt une
mauvaise partie même pour lui même
contre Kardashian etc et là le cadeau
tombé du ciel en tout cas pour l'intérêt
du tournoi c'est quand même hyper
intéressant de voir que 45 du coup se
fait attraper par par artemief et que du
coup les joueurs peuvent revenir
derrière tu vois que derrière on a la
remarque de forgotton
moi aussi mais parce que là c'est pas en
fait
là il y a rien eu de provoqué par par
tamiable si artémia c'est mis mal au
temps c'est ce qui a provoqué la gave de
Carlson mais normalement ça se passe pas
comme ça
tout le tournoi merci à lui merci à
Magnus et en plus d'être très bons
échecs il aime bien le spectacle le
grand spectacle merci à oui bien sûr
est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on irait pas
avoir un petit peu ce qui se passe chez
Abou auto qui est le seul joueur du coup
à pouvoir revenir sur 45 bon
Artémis qui vient de de revenir du coup
sur carrassen mais après torov qui du
coup à 7 points et demi et pour y
revenir du coup alors il joue vite on a
un peu oublié dans ce moment là pas du
tout cité mais visite on rappelle que
c'est un top player le joueur indien
et du coup une position qui alors je
vois la jauge qui est indique à gale je
préfère tous les jours la voir avec
avec les Blancs parce que la structure
est plus saine
qui est un petit peu faible des fois je
peux enfin il faut surveiller toujours
qui peut être une faiblesse difficile à
atteindre pour le moment
le dynamisme noir peut compenser mais
c'est dur quand même un îlot de pions en
fait c'est un groupe de pions si vous
voulez et à l'époque ils sont connectés
les uns avec les autres et moi vous avez
de l'eau mieux vous êtes généralement
parce que les pions se défendent entre
eux donc là j'ai moi j'ai deux îlots
deux groupes de pions donc en très
solide donc a priori je risque pas de
barbecion
un deuxième îlot ici et surtout un
troisième élément ce qu'ils font qu'en
fait les pions sont un peu déconnectés
et il peut y avoir des faiblesses dans
la structure donc
de chaîne de pions aux échecs et qu'on
aime défendre les pions avec les pions
pour que nos pièces ne soient pas
esclaves voilà de la défense des pions
de notre propre camp mais essayez
d'éviter en fait ce genre de choses dans
vos parties des pions isolés
surtout sur les côtés
gardez vos pures un peu connecté entre
eux c'est un bon conseil pour essayer de
ne pas affaiblir votre structure mais
après au on voit qu'il bafoue les règles
pour de bonnes raisons déjà
abdosa Torah il a fait cette concession
là parce qu'il s'est dit mon pion à 5
mon adversaire ne peut pas l'atteindre
il n'est pas sur plein de semis ouverte
c'est le pion blanc à Cap n'était pas là
le pion A5 serait vraiment une faiblesse
parce que la tour la teinte très
facilement or là on voit la difficulté
et pour le cavalier blanc et pour la
Tour Blanche devenir attaquer à 5 donc
c'est pas si facile de travailler cette
position
qui dit que c'est toujours
ça console en fait de devoir gaffer un
champion du monde pour te dire un petit
peu la garde de carcène si moi j'ai un
élève qui fait une gaffe comme ça en
vrai je trouve que c'est quand même une
gaffe très grossière donc je trouve que
c'est tu vois même un élève qui est qui
peut avoir 1500 à l'eau je vais faire
quand même franchement enfin bien sûr
c'est pas normal il faut pas faire les
vérifications et en plus les pires de la
gamme de Carlson vu le contexte
encore c'est vraiment là c'est vraiment
abusé pas pour bébé pour un joueur de de
de de
comme ça franchement c'est tilt quoi
enfin c'est quand même je suis pas
content après moi-même du tout et
imaginaire on parle de du meilleur
joueur tous les temps on ne tarit pas
d'éloges à chaque fois
avec avec stouf sur 45 donc là c'est un
petit peu choquant dans ce contexte là
mais ça arrive au meilleur il avait
besoin d'une piqûre de rappel je peux
vous dire que
il risque de finir fort quand même il
avait très très bien joué jusque là je
le vois pas faire n'importe quoi mais il
va sans vouloir et il va avoir envie de
réparer son erreur en juin une grosse
partie je pense c'est ça bon après la
prochaine partie elle est blanche
il a les blancs il est toujours en tête
de tournoi et il faut que
artemière suivent encore la cadence on
sait pas encore sûr enfin tout se joue
c'est pas c'est pas clair encore mais
vous savez 45 généralement quand il perd
une partie c'est pas le genre à tilter
dans le sens qu'il va complètement faire
nimple à partir d'après c'est plutôt le
mental d'un champion en fait quand il
parle une partie et ben il veut se
refaire et il veut montrer aux gens
qu'il est quoi et ça c'est quand même
quelque chose qu'on voit chez Carcel qui
qui est assez important et très souvent
je sais pas si vous avez des armes comme
ça mais très souvent quand 45 par une
partie vous allez le voir derrière
enchaîner deux trois victoires quoi et
en tout cas enfin ça je l'ai vu dans
beaucoup de tournois Kevin tout à fait
on disait pareil de Kasparov d'ailleurs
que c'était des ce sont des joueurs qui
ne perdent jamais de partie de suite bon
il faut pas il va pas nous faire mentir
incandissa généralement on peut bien me
passer le mec mais
objectivement voilà ce sont des Twitter
des chiens dans le bon sens du terme ces
joueurs là Carlson kasporov vraiment ils
sont géniaux et en plus ce sont des
ultras compétiteurs des battants en fait
et c'est hyper important de se nourrir
de ses qualités là de se dire que ça ne
fait pas toujours les vérifications on
vient de le voir mais globalement c'est
une partie sur 5000 où il fait une
bêtise de stack Abila et n'oublions pas
que c'est dans du rapide ce qui est plus
choquant c'est qu'il a fait alors qu'il
avait 10 minutes à la pendule il s'est
vu je pense qu'il surnagait tellement
dans ce tournoi qu'il a perdu dans
attention
direct la partie tu vois tu c'est normal
de vouloir jouer un peu vite parce que
ton adversaire avait à la pendule une
minute on avait 11 et par contre tu veux
jouer vite pour être un peu la pression
l'adversaire donc qui dit je vais vite
bah moi vérifier prendre clairement donc
c'est à la fois bien et pas bien là on a
vu vraiment l'exemple que dans lequel ça
peut des fois être pas bien tu vois tout
à fait et donc
bon après c'est les risques mais c'est
vrai qu'il aurait pu être plus sérieux à
ce niveau là quand un champion du monde
quand tu es carracène une erreur comme
celle-là ça devrait pas arriver ça
complètement
c'est pas du tout le style de la maison
on vient d'assistant un grand moment
d'échec un monde faiblesse de Carlson
c'est ce qui est extrêmement rare et
si tu vois il va s'en servir une grosse
gaffe comme ça dans le rang top top
niveau bah je t'aurais dit je t'aurais
dit n'est pas
déjà fait parce que c'est un joueur qui
joue très vite et qui d'ailleurs il a
gavé contre le store un peu de la même
manière tout à fait mais on l'a déjà vu
pour Carlsen récemment il a quand même
plus gaffé que d'habitude exemple le
match qu'on avait commenté donc je l'ai
vu gafak contre nepomatchi et en randoms
aussi c'était qu'on n'a qu'à Moura une
énorme gaffe même si c'est du random de
chasse c'était pareil ma position tu
avais une menace en un coup dame 4 bon
on s'en rappelle
merci pour le lancer view TV pardon
merci pour le soutien je vois que toi tu
as un manteau Quechua moi j'ai ma
doudoune qui fait parler elle est super
franchement avec ça tu es bien je suis
mauvais
je pense que c'est important pour les
prochains streams le problème c'est que
moi depuis les Canaries ça va être un
peu compliqué de mettre la doudoune mais
je mettrai la clim
mais c'est pas mal petite un petit
manteau Quechua je pense que tu es bien
aussi Vico DV tu dois bien me régaler
devant le dans le dans le stream sinon
on nous citer un Charlie et nous disait
que avec une petite une petite couette
on serait bien aussi à la guiru à la
guiru dans le dans le monde
footballistique et ben ça se fait aussi
mettez-vous bien dans cette période
hivernale et de rigueur énergétique
voilà petite pensée petite pensée pour
tout le monde pour en fait petite pensée
pour tous ceux qui ne vivent pas aux
Canaries quoi grossièrement voilà ce
qu'on peut dire ce que stouffe il se
régale
encore hier
non c'est impossible hier il a plus
malade là on a plus de plus qui arrive
là on est le jour de pluie il y a tout
le sable des bon ben tu sais que le
canari a beaucoup de plages etc et puis
on est d'ailleurs pas très très loin
une énorme dune de sable qui s'appelle
Maspalomas et ben beaucoup de vent enfin
il y a eu hier c'est pas très beau et
toutes les voitures sont remplies de
sable donc du coup je suis pas très
content qu'il faut envoyer le laver les
voitures mais non non
retour tu peux aller laver ta bagnole du
coup je touche
sûrement le plan de la journée
quand tu parles de l'AS c'est là où
avait lieu le célèbre tournoi stouffe
c'est c'est une des une des plages les
plus importantes de canari c'est un roi
le plus je pense le plus touristique de
Lille avec des dunes de sable c'est un
peu tu vois qu'on a d'une du Pilat un
truc comme ça mais beaucoup beaucoup
plus grand et c'est immense c'est génial
c'est le désert quoi et je vous dirai
pas qu'à la fin des plages et ben c'est
les plages nudistes
mais bon sinon du coup ça je me suis
rendu compte
[Musique]
un jour Combins
avec Windside on faisait ça doit ça doit
plaire au chat d'ailleurs on faisait on
faisait un petit un petit footing sur la
plage il y a quelques années et puis
Robinson Robinson j'étais étonné qui
n'arrive pas à ce moment-là et il nous
écoute quand même il nous surveille
surveille je teste je teste
mais bon donc du coup du coup voilà
votre footing c'était les fesses à l'air
ou pas juste pour précision moi j'ai
envie de savoir si tu c'est assez
excitant quand même
absolument
Gilgamesh il est un peu sceptique par
rapport à ton histoire il pense que
on savait pas que que c'était c'était
une plage comme ça
[Musique]
on revient et puis en fait en fait bah
si je conseille pas
ça ça arrive ça arrive ce genre ce genre
de petite de petite anecdote
mais c'est possible c'est fort possible
que ton footing était plus long que le
mien
il sert il s'est rattrapé il s'est
rattrapé la spécifié que je crois qu'il
voulait me tendre la perche
[Rires]
pour ce genre de choses du coup on voit
les vrais sportifs
commentateur et sportif sur leur temps
perdu incroyable du coup les noirs qui
jouent très solides et d'ailleurs les
gens qui peuvent un jour commence à
prendre l'avantage avec des fois des des
C4 qui peuvent arriver on voit des tu as
la structure qui peut être un jour un
peu fragile même cavaler des plâtre et
essayer de mettre un peu la pression
je trouve la partie
remarquable donc de haut niveau pour
tout vous dire parce que il est clair
qu'au départ de la position les blancs
possédaient peut-être un lézard avantage
pratique maintenant c'est très différent
puisque le la faiblesse en 5 se voit de
moins en moins et l'aspect central
l'avantage centrale des Noirs
se voit de plus en plus a permis une
centralisation plus forte du roi noir
maintenant les Noirs commencent aussi à
voir de meilleures pièces je pense que
ça fera quand même mieux cette partie
mais il a obtenu des petites choses des
petits améliorations de pièces assez
assez convaincante côté Abdou sakuraf
maintenant c'est difficile d'obtenir
plus j'ai l'impression il va essayer on
a vu tout à l'heure et il a pas voulu
répéter il y avait une possibilité de
proposer cela mais il a préféré
améliorer légitimement son roi
essayer de mettre pression bien sûr
des cartes cavaliers C4 donc je pense
que c'est ça reste toujours assez neutre
mais c'est une petite pression qui
pressing il viande ici
j'ai du mal à trouver en fait le moyen
de passer sous pour être tout à fait
franc les Blancs n'ont pas grand chose
mais ils sont solides
[Musique]
il y a beaucoup de joueurs qui se
prennent plus trop la tête ils veulent
ils veulent voir ce qui se passe pour
les Blitz
que les joueurs de qui sont très très
bien placés là qui doivent être un bloc
[Musique]
c'est complètement foutu moi ouais
j'ai l'impression que c'est
trois c'est pour éviter les perpettes
tourbées un tour B2 ouais j'ai aussi
tout reprendre
ça marche
ça marche pas du tout parce qu'on voit
surprise ici je pense que les valves a
été pas encore à jour c'est pour ça qu'à
l'indiqué l'égalité c'était pas du tout
égal en fait pas confiance avec valent
quand même
la position et du coup regardez qui
baguette franchement qui fait un gros
tournoi quand même hein
franchement parce qu'il a quand même tu
vois il a l'argent
il a battu diri bah tu aimes VL bah tu
grichu
dans tout le tournoi et c'est contre
Magnus sinon il a joué toutes ces
parties à fond il a perdu
une belle victoire
et
donc franchement
ça a changé un petit peu mais bon
peut-être pas pour grand chose la partie
de contrôle juste horreur
il pousse quoi il pousse il pousse
regardez au final après Descartes dans
la case mais un jour
ok alors le café
parce qu'il y avait des idées de G5 bien
sûr sur dans ces positions là ça existe
toujours mais
moi puisque bien sûr la tour H2 est
protégée
et peut-être essayer de penser que le
roi est actif
j'ai pas très l'impression mais bon ok
on va voir je pense toujours
je n'avais pas vu ouais moi non plus
j'ai l'impression que c'est très bizarre
comme choix
parce que je dois manger le pion et puis
comme ça
le roi non blanc regardez en plus j'ai
le droit aussi de le garder par roi G3
rouages 4 mais si je mange bien
il joue vraiment sur ça ça me paraît
bizarre de faire all-in un peu ça de
position alors que ça a l'air très
compliqué quand même ouais j'aime pas
trop ce choix là mais bon on va voir
peut-être que il a mieux compris la
position que nous
on a la position sur les juges
[Musique]
même ça c'était bizarre il y avait roi
F4 et il commençait à être un peu mal
ce que je veux dire c'est pas logique de
toucher alors que sans toucher tu es sûr
de faire nul quoi donc
Jimmy Vico pour ceux qui connaissent
voilà on a les deux et même Usain Bolt
en D4 ne va pas résister voilà
on met le cavalier là voilà et puis on
pousse les deux pions
après le roi peut venir manger celui-là
peut-être mais il y a quand même le
renard
mais bon ça a l'air perdant position à
deux résultats en tout cas pour pour
visiter évidemment qu'il l'a compris
grosse gaffe de
d'abdu on c'est parti
contre visite
qu'on a pas vu dans le tournoi qui
revient du coup très très bien
ouais on n'a pas vu et qui avait fait
une énorme partie pour revenir
on avait dit un qui est il était en
difficulté à un moment mais il était
bien revenu on trouvait et finalement
il se fait avoir
et du coup c'était assez marrant tu nous
as mis la fiche de visite on a vu tous
les deux et en fait tu as perdu contre
Morzine sinon il fait un très gros
tournoi
pas très gros tournoi il n'avait pas
fait n'importe quoi ouais bon c'est pas
non plus
non mais si tu veux regarde il gagne de
rentrer fort en fait
il avait bien assuré un grand maître
avec des blancs nuls Avec les Noirs pas
un grand maître avec les Blancs nul avec
des noirs et ronde 5 hyper contre
Morzine avec les blancs puis continuer
avec les Noirs gargle et blanc nul noir
gangs jusqu'à regagner avec les Noirs à
la ronde d'avant et là il va sans doute
batte abdosa torov avec les pièces
blanches
100% non il a perdu contre mon rosier
que des victoires à part une défaite
énorme ici on peut le dire
du coup
et ben moi j'ai quatre et ça va être
plié
parce que le pion peut avancer mais en
fait le cavalier peut rien faire
pour les deux joueurs
je peux pousser bon il y a toré chacun
qui file donc ça c'est assez marrant ça
petit thème de cavaluation réciproque
qui ne marche pas d'ailleurs mais qui
pourrait un jour marcher d'ailleurs
voilà ça c'est un gros F4 va gagner ici
et puis on remballe
on est dans le carré du pion du pion des
trois après trois
voilà
le cavalier en C4 tient
par exemple échec il y a pas de risque
de d'embrouille
[Musique]
voilà si on veut on mange l'option et tu
remontes et
ce coup la tête pas content d'où ça
t'auras évidemment une grosse gaffe au
bout de trois jours de tournoi les
joueurs sont sont quand même fatigués on
sent vraiment un des blender un peu de
partout on a vu carcennes on voit encore
bien sûr Abdou qui qui est plus
excusable que la gaffe de Carlson parce
qu'évidemment il y avait moins de temps
et il a bien joué carlsan il s'est
déconcentré parce qu'il avait plein
d'avance au temps il a fait un peu
l'enfant on peut le dire du numéro un
mondial qui est le meilleur joueur tous
les temps qui explose tout le monde qui
joue super bien mais il s'est
déconcentré et il a il a il a commis une
grave faute là tout ça t'auras donc
de temps chez les deux joueurs ça peut
arriver de côté on a Jules qui a gagné
sa partie contre un grand maître à 2485
on peut regarder un peu ce qui s'est
passé rapidement
une Anglaise lui a donné la paire de fou
et regardez c'est très joli coup
ouverture des cases noires C5 l'idée
c'est que si on prend la je prends là du
coup il va réussir à ouvrir du coup la
position et les quasiment pour ce joli
four
échec à 4
et au fur et à mesure donc
[Musique]
le joueur en face
quelque chose de modeste je peux vous
dire ouais
il a fait ce qu'on fait avec stouf dans
un Bullet sur chasse.com la feuille
l'attaque l'attaque qui marche pas
ils sont passés bon après vous voyez
encore une fois c'est un grand maître
c'est non non bien sûr
on voit beaucoup en fin de tournoi des
quand même beaucoup de parties
backlin quoi
c'était bon
une partie qui était à oublier en place
pour le blitz de demain c'est ça et
Sébastien qui a perdu
contre 2003 un masque Sébastien qui
avait les blancs
d'intérêt pour jouer cette femme tournoi
ça va être dur de jouer
les deux dernières rondes ça va être
long pour ça du coup donc là de pions
pour
le l'activité le développement un
avantage net qui est là peut-être
ok apparemment donc on voit qu'il y a
des sacrifices qui peuvent arriver en
e67 et
[Musique]
le petit rock j'avais cavallé aussi
peut-être
l'idée en fait
avec ton fou B3 méchant et si la tour
vient ici
sur
dame ici et ben j'ai bien prendre le set
que je lis parce que le plateau est
toujours cloué
et du coup il y a eu des imbécis pour
venir défendre faut B3 et le cavalier 8
qui vient se replacer en C6 qui vient
défendre aussi
parce que l'autre a réussi à le museler
un cadeau de Ciroc une fois que les
noirs sont beaucoup mieux et il a réussi
après à sortir toutes ces pièces il y a
un pion de plus une fois que je suis
développé
ils sont adversaire
vraiment devant
en tournant énorme et qui vient de
perdre
sa première contrepert enfin un tournoi
dommage
parce que là ça va être assez démotivant
de jouer les deux dernières rondes c'est
ça contre évidemment deux joueurs plus
faibles
et pour il a pas grand chose à gagner
lui ce qu'il voulait faire je pensais
jouer des joueurs de tout premier plan
et ça ne sera plus le cas dans ce
tournoi c'est ça
il y a des longs jeu oui ça compte pour
les lofides du rapides donc c'est une
raison
de haut niveau font vraiment moins
attention à leur et leur rapide et Blitz
coell Hollande ou non c'est beaucoup
d'ailleurs c'est beaucoup moins
important mais le hellolan attribue tous
les titres aux échecs le hello rapide et
Blitz sont une valeur indicative ou
valeur pour les tournois rapides et
Blitz mais c'est vraiment des hello
moins significatifs
et avant la prochaine ronde on sait pas
encore ma coccyx parce que ça dépend de
la dernière partie c'est la dernière
celle-là c'est tout ou non il y en a
plusieurs
[Musique]
fou qui va se terminer du coup très bien
je crois que c'est là c'est le coup la
dernière avec l'autre alors on va
peut-être mettre les classements à jour
tout pour voir un petit peu donc on a un
jour je peux vous le montrer de toute
façon une partie ce qui se qui se joue
enfin la partie on peut dire alors je
vais vous juger
en partie long il faut impérativement
préparer son adversaire avec la base de
parti c'est mieux en fait c'est pas que
ça vous permet de gagner c'est que ça
vous permet dans l'ouverture de bien
démarrer galindor il y a aucune
certitude mais vous pouvez tomber dessus
c'est comme pour un étudiant préparer
ces examens bah c'est mieux de pas faire
d'impasse et si on a bossé à fond un
chapitre qui tombe on est hyper content
et ça peut nous favoriser dans la partie
c'est vraiment l'objectif de la
préparation favoriser l'ouverture après
ça dépend de ton niveau aussi
parce que
ça la préparation dans les ouvertures
c'est c'est plutôt pour les joueurs qui
sont vraiment entre bon joueur de club
et genre professionnel
plus vous êtes fort aux échecs plus la
prépa va avoir un impact parce que plus
les joueurs ont des ouvertures
référencées en 1600 hello bah je suis
pas sûr que la préparation d'ouverture
les adversaires sont si importantes que
ça
parce que tu vois t'as pas besoin
d'avoir des connaissances théoriques à
ce niveau là qui sont si importantes en
fait parce qu'en plus
dans les bases déjà ou non tu peux en
discuter des choses des fois mais c'est
pas besoin de faire des grosses de son
adversaire internet ça peut être une
idée et ça dépend au niveau calcules ou
par exemple si tu es un 1600 adultes
ou si tu as un 1600 qui est jaune et qui
joue le top jeune par exemple déjà ça
sera une différence notable voilà mais
en Open quand tu joues des joueurs à 14
15 16 ans ils ont pas de partie dans la
base il est très difficile de faire une
bonne préparation
la bonne préparation est due à la
connaissance du début adverse sinon tu
peux pas réellement faire une bonne
préparation comme nous le dit
salut titine
alors le point classement ce qu'on peut
le faire donc sur pas mis à jour de
toute façon les la partie est encore en
cours mais je peux vous montrer moi ce
que j'ai fait alors attends ce que je
vais faire du coup vu que je vais
revenir sur le la caméra d'avant de la
salle de jeux pour vous déjà et en plus
j'ai le résultat
on voit là j'ai qui enfin la caméra qui
est sur une partie du de l'Open féminin
je le connais pas les joueuses
malheureusement pas vous dire qui c'est
qui elles sont tu veux que je te dise
uses puis dans le championnat rapide et
Blitz
il peut y avoir des joueuses assez
confidentielles qui arrivent
sont des joueurs à 2300-2400 pas toutes
les connaître
je crois qu'on arrive à voir
la jeune femme qui est blonde elle me
dit quelque chose je crois qu'elles sont
dans la finale roi tour cavalier contre
roi tour
donc en plus ça va durer longtemps alors
le roi me paraît à la bande à le roi
noir donc il y a plus de chance de gain
pour les blancs dans cette finale qui
est objectivement nul là on y arrive
pas s'il allait noir rouler blanc je
pense qu'il avait noir mais c'est pas
sûr
donc avec trois faux
et en fait son roi est pas si bien placé
à regarder
il a mis son roi dans le mauvais coin et
je crois qu'il va peut-être perdre
la partie j'ai vu gain normalement il y
a une enfilade voilà entre le fou et la
case de maths et je vais harceler le
faux constamment il sait qu'il a perdu
rien pour moi c'est perdant cette
position
tout le temps c'est ça
dans la couleur inverse de votre fou
pour en fait donc il y a une finale
comme ça alors je sais plus qui c'était
la partie
excuse
là ça va être abandon on a dit 7 de très
forts grands matchs
gagnent la casachat et l'attaque du foie
est fou G3 Tour Eiffel 3 gagne
plus qu'à bouger la tour tu as raison tu
as raison c'était aujourd'hui
je vais retrouver assez tout à l'heure
c'était dans les plus forts en plus
évidemment et on a cité voilà c'était ni
même
parce que du coup le renard doit bouger
il a très très bien joué enfin c'est
normal de demander la nul on est au
centre il vient de perdre une finale
nulle théorique mais il a le droit de
demander la règle des 50 croustilles
ou 89 ah oui plus 50 non non pas du tout
quoi pas du tout
il a fait la moitié
c'est normal c'est la règle en tout cas
mais il se ridiculise là oui pour le
coup
mais mais après tu vois je pense que
c'est pas anormal de le faire en tout
cas qu'est-ce qu'il a fait fais voir ce
que je mange est-ce que tu peux nous
montrer
la technique ouais parce que
c'est pas vraiment
ah oui non mais là moi j'ai 7 par contre
c'est en fait vous voyez que pour faire
nul ici il faut amener le roi en fait
dans un des coins
opposé au fou de classe noir
et après c'est pas sympa genre voilà il
peut y avoir ça
ça peut faire peur oui bien sûr mais ça
fait peur donc du coup je pense que ce
qu'il faut faire c'est à dire
tu dois en fait tu peux faire nul de
manière différente tu contrôles la case
F6 parce que ton roi est en H6 quoi tu
vois ce que je veux dire c'est le
contrôler la l'opposition du roi adverse
ouais c'est un malheureusement pour les
raisons def qui a un très fort grand
maître qui a été plus de 2700
un peu
un peu difficile par rapport à ce que
représente la finale en règle générale
ou c'est nul dans 95% des cas très
facilement c'est ça
il a le droit bon c'est des
interprétations différentes mais en tout
cas il va être déçu parce que il a bel
et bien perdu cette cette partie son
adversaire va très bien travaillé
on a réussi à le mettre sur le bord dans
une situation difficile
il a bien bloqué dans son coincifier et
il a vraiment fait une belle partie
belle finale pourtant nul au départ
c'est pour ça qu'il faut faire attention
aux évals de l'ordi
qui ne vous dit pas si la position est
facile ou non à jouer
c'est clair mais en pratique retenez
vraiment un matelas d'un couleur inverse
de votre fou j'ai l'exemple de la partie
de la partie contre de neiman pour tout
à l'heure il vérifie comme nous regarde
à l'écran c'est assez rigolo je trouve
c'est une vérification à l'ordi tu vois
elle fait comme toi la jeune femme
arbitre
qui regarde la dernière prise qui a eu
lieu
c'est un peu le même genre
ou en fait les pions vont être échangés
à un moment donné
donc du coup et si pain avec les Noirs
doit mettre son roi dans un des coins
noirs parce qu'il a un faux de casse
blanche donc regardez hop voilà
mais tu vas te diriger vers le point
noir ce qui est normal et maintenant que
je suis en coin noir et ben je j'attends
faites attention de ne pas vous faire
mater en un coup évidemment
très bien on passe au matin un coup
comme ça ce serait quand même dommage
regardez là voilà
et on met toujours le roi dans le coin
regardez il peut rien faire et on va
vous mettre le classement vous inquiétez
pas parce que la ronde est finie je
pense maintenant mais on a une belle
explication comme ça vous progressez
on pense qu'on a ce match en fait pas du
tout regardez si la tour vient ici c'est
pattes c'est ça c'est l'astuce qui vous
permettra
alors qu'avec le fou de la mauvaise
couleur il y a pas de pâte il y a
qu'on a vu avant avec le voyez il faut
H7 je me défends et je faisais les
retours exactement il y a rien à faire
c'est complètement nul c'est très facile
le patte de côté ça peut être rangé 8 ou
en H7 là ou là et dans la partie qu'on
vient juste de voir la partie du coup de
de
rien de SAF vous voyez c'est la même
chose sauf que là on décalé d'une rangée
la huitième rangée elle est pour
personne donc du coup après regardez et
lui échec le fou qui vient devant la
tour qui attend et du coup je suis
obligé de bouger mon roi là et du coup
je mange le fou et c'est ma top prochain
alors que quand je suis encore là je
peux pas bouger mon rond en fait je peux
pas monter en H9 ça n'existe pas
exactement que donc c'est la grosse
différence pourquoi mettre le roi dans
le coin adverse du fou c'est la seule
chose et ça il faut il faut que vous en
souvenez quand vous jouez vos parties
parce que on n'a pas forcément le temps
de réfléchir à tout ça pendant qu'on
joue ce qu'on est en finale on a souvent
peu de temps la pendule si vous
connaissez les principes là c'est très
simple le classement on va vous le
montrer tout de suite alors le
classement
de nul dans ces cas-là c'est une règle
qui fait partie du jeu donc en fait un
mur
tu vois c'est là j'aurais su qu'il y
avait eu que 25 coups quand même ça
m'aurait saoulé de demander non mais
c'est qui a 25 coups c'est là pour le
coup c'est ridicule je suis d'accord
mais quand ça fait un manque par exemple
tu vois la finale de de
iriasis contre Kemar un moment donné tu
as joué 200 coups
tu peux
l'idée que l'autre aurait demandé donc
voilà exactement donc tu peux tu peux tu
peux toujours demander alors il y a eu
aussi il y a eu une partie que je
t'avais dit hier il y avait un match
c'était le tournoi des candidates et
c'était l'élimination directe tu avais
une fille qui avait défendu pendant je
sais pas combien de temps
et au final à la fin les gars fait le
cheminée et elle abandonne mais le
nombre abandonne et ben en fait elle
pouvait demander la nulle mais elle a
pas fait tu vois et elle abandonnée
parce qu'elle a pas peut-être qu'elle
est même pas pensé peut-être que voilà
et du coup là alors que si elle avait
récupéré la ville elle aurait voilà mais
tu vois bon là l'enjeu ici il y a pas un
gros enjeu et je pense qu'il joue rien
du tout mais je pense que par rapport à
l'enjeu par rapport aussi à au scénario
un peu de la partie tu vois tu peux ou
pas demander là je suis d'accord qu'ici
c'est un peu ridicule il y a eu un coup
tu vois le mec il y a pas que 50 coups
par contre sinon ben moi je trouve ça
pas dégueu de demander c'est une règle
qui fait partie du jeu
et puis c'est c'est comme ça tu vois
regarde tu dis que tu sais c'est
grotesque ça te déshonneur mais en fait
la finale tour
en théoriquement elle est nulle assez
facilement et aussi tu vois que
gadimbali qui la joue alors qu'en fait
c'est facile tu vois c'est aussi un
petit peu à l'envers on peut aussi
tourner un petit peu si tu veux la
question ok tu joues une complètement à
a particulier quand même du fait pas
vraiment dans le dans le coin donc je
suis d'accord mais
voilà pour moi si la règle existe ce que
bah elle doit être utilisée à bon
escient là c'est pas forcément mais mais
voilà pour moi moi à sa place au bout
d'un coup je l'aurais pas fait mais si
je vois que c'est pas clair etc bah je
l'aurais sûrement fait aussi parce que
c'est des règles du jeu et puis c'est
comme ça quoi tu vois donc est-ce qu'on
est-ce que c'est pas pour autant que
j'aurais été ridicule ou que j'aurais
été tu vois parce que c'est une arnaque
voilà moi je le je le vois comme ça en
tout cas
exactement
on peut tout faire si c'est dans les
règles
plus ou moins plus ou moins comment dire
si des fois avant moi une fois je me
souviens j'avais une partie en
tournoi rapide et j'avais un jeu contre
Jean-Marc degre qui est grand maître tu
vois et j'avais tout fout un retour sauf
que enfin moi j'avais la tour mais le
problème en fait c'est que je
j'avais pas d'échiquier retransmis et du
coup personne savait comme un con
l'avait fait j'ai défendu pour rentrer
longtemps puis je finis par café mais
comment c'est
mais dans l'idée tu vois je pense que
quand tu es pas clair il faut il faut
pas oser en fait enfin moi je pense que
il faut oser en fait
c'est rigolo tu me cite quand même la
personne Jean-Marc de grave
contre toi quoi c'est
Jean-Marc il a parlé Jean-Marc je vous
écoute on salue et on te félicite pour
cette performance
et il a perdu
la tour puis la dernière puis après la
fête perdue la finale droite le roi fou
comme nous l'a montré Riaz ANSF là dans
cette partie donc le classement le
classement vous attendez tous à
il est ici donc on a Carlsen qui était
qualité du coup avec artemiev avec 8 et
demi chacun et je trouve tu vas nous
superbe il est apparu regardez
maintenant incroyable il est là
vous avez vu le technicien un peu c'est
pas moi qui aurait fait ça je peux vous
le dire
et donc on a ça et on a 5 joueurs aussi
à 8 points on a Kemer on a duboff
fedochf Kawana Vidy tout ça l'embuscade
et encore à 7h30 c'est pas c'est pas
terminé parce que genre à 7h30 peuvent
aussi revenir et encore deux parties
donc on a là on voit en Ariana et
reghazi Sirine a manque plein d'Indiens
on a aussi à vous autorov qui est
lui-même Champion du monde en titre on a
guéri Douda ton petit poulain qui qui
revient
par contre des pots il a intérêt il a il
a
cette
maxime qui est revenu
et cette fois il faut avoir cette ennemi
là si on veut revenir ouais c'était demi
là maintenant il faut il faudra faire
9 ça va être neuf
[Musique]
qui va se jouer sur moi à 9h30 maximum
qui bon normalement enfin dans ma tête
il y aurait dû avoir Carl scène à 9 et
artiami Artémis à 8 pour l'intérêt pour
le spectacle c'est c'est mieux ce
classement évidemment mais on vous
rappelle que Carlson vient de faire une
gaffe énorme ici avec 10 minutes
d'avance à la pendule contre artemief
donner une pièce en un coup ce qui fait
que enfin en deux coups mais bon c'était
largement visible surtout avec l'avance
autant et qu'il vient de relancer le
championnat qu'il était en train
d'écraser
avoir la réaction d'orgueil du champion
on en a parlé ce qu'on a bien tisé les
choses ou non ce qu'on a bien lu ce qui
allait se passer à voir
faut pas oublier que mdr il tourne en
bas
et du coup il a un départage je peux
vous dire il faut un gros départage et
je pense que ce sera 9h30 moi
c'est-à-dire que 9 minimum c'est 9,5
arrive à 9 en fait l'un des partages qui
qui est pas bon et là j'ai des AD qui
sont beaucoup moins forts enfin il y a
aucun quasiment adversaire de Maxime qui
sont dans le temps du coup il va être
derrière au départage il manque le demi
point contre Seb après l'aurait eu un
tournoi différent etc mais c'est vrai
qu'il a joué il a joué un petit peu
modestement contre contre Seb et du coup
bah forcément je pense à ce moment-là
quand ils ont fait je pense qu'il savait
il avait déjà accepté qui qui ferait pas
grand chose dans le rapide et qui
voulait garder ses forces pour le Blitz
je pense parce que normalement Maxime
doit tenter quelque chose même si son
copain même si c'est un bon choix dans
le contexte affectif des deux joueurs
etc qui se connaissent très très bien du
coup c'est toujours compliqué c'est
match là les les champions souvent
arrivent à passer au dessus parce que
ils ont beaucoup d'amis dans le circuit
là c'est vraiment un de ses plus proches
sans doute
ceci explique cela même si d'un point de
vue purement sportif c'était une demi
contre perf une demi grosse contreperf
forcément de toute façon tout est scruté
quand vous êtes leader de la délégation
française donc ça prête plus à débat
pour autant il va essayer de se
rattraper au niveau du Blitz ce sera ça
sera une autre tout autre histoire tout
autre tournoi voilà ce qu'on peut dire
du coup le départage pour la première
place oui c'est c'est des Bliss
pour le départage sinon bah c'est des
partages standard avec des points
adversaires etc exactement mais Maxime
je suis pas sûr que ça soit si chaud
pour un gars comme Carlsen c'est à dire
que c'est des bêtes de scène si tu veux
et là il va il va avoir les blancs
l'expérience et on a vu dans le speed
chasse des fois des moments mais où je
me serais complètement désuni stouf où
tu prends trois quatre bulles d'affilée
contre un joueur de ton niveau et les
mecs repartent et souvent inverse la
situation
écarlsen avec Naka en partie de ces
cadence là me paraît être un joueur
hyper fort psychologiquement
de la ronde de la de la ronde 12 ils
sont pas encore arrivés sur cheeseccum
et je peux vous le donner en
avant-première on a des belles belles
affiches ici super on a quinzaine blanc
contre Caravana ça c'est pas forcément
la bonne nouvelle parce que du coup
personne avec les Blancs vous savez
qu'il est juste incroyable mais carwana
avec les Noirs il est quand même aussi
très solide bon après il y a eu le match
de
au quartier n'a complètement
adopté Cavana il lui a mis des séries de
10-0
je pense
mais il y a quand même l'aspect
psychologique du match qui s'est joué il
y a quelques jours
mais bon c'est vrai que Carola c'est pas
le meilleur adversaire ici dans ce
format pour 45 qui allait blanc et doit
essayer de marquer pour prendre de
l'avance sur cette adversaire parce qu'à
côté il y a quand même des des parties
qui sont quand même assez ouvertes on a
fait de la CIA blanc contre artemief
c'est très ouvert on les a pas cité
aussi gamer blanc contre vidite
et à 7h30 on a un rapport qui joue
contre deux boiv qui lui a 8
donc c'est très très ouvert devant et je
pense que Carlson aurait aimé jouer
n'importe lequel d'autres le carwana
avec les Blancs
après avoir fait une énorme gaffe il
joue un de ses plus gros challenger donc
c'est intéressant et régalez je contre
quiz touffe et regga-z
il est où il a les Noirs contre nepo ah
oui mais eagasie en fait il a il a un
élo assez bas si tu veux un rapide
et du coup il a pas trop de chance entre
guillemets dans cette tirage ce qui veut
vraiment qu'en contrôler les très forts
joueurs et
mais ouais il a une moyenne élo en face
qui est juste monstrueuse
contre double noire contre Niall Sarine
c'est tout est chaud je vais voir si
vous les avez forcément sur cette somme
qui viennent d'arriver c'est il y a que
des super joueurs mais bien sûr vous
avez les plus en forme de ce tournoi là
et demain ça sera une autre histoire en
blitz certains qui ont été
mauvais par rapport à leur niveau réel
dans le rapide vont être excellents
Blitz on le sait
c'est ça et et
Nakamura là qui qui a six nul d'affilée
je viens de regarder qui je pense lui a
complètement accepté
il se prend plus la tête Nakamura
mvl qui est quand même à 7 points je
vois contre aminda Sam avec les Blancs
meilleurs joueurs africain
donc on voit aussi les aidos qui sont
assez bas on voit une personne qui a
2567 en rapide alors que en partie lente
il a quasiment 2700
c'est pas c'est pas des appareils et
donc voilà elle va gagner je vois bien
elle finira 9 quand même c'est possible
qui représente un challenge pour lui
donc
si gagne celle-là la dernière il
essaiera de la gagner bien sûr parce que
pour finir un œuf
du matin il aurait pu faire un
rapprocher au classement et pourquoi pas
jouer pour vibrer un petit peu plus ça
la dernière alors Sébastien Mazet joue
avec les Noirs contre pranave V parce
que tu connais ça me dit quelque chose
je l'ai vu je sais plus enquête tournoi
mais c'est un jeune Indien qui vient de
passer grand maître qui a 25 50
maintenant pas facile comme
appareils contre lui alors moi je sais
que pranave il a quasiment 3000 sur le
cheescom
c'est clair c'est un très gros Blizzard
et c'est pas un bon style pour Seb après
une défaite quand je pense que là
on va voir et Jules qui joue contre
Mustafa yelmaz qui est un très gros
genre c'est internet
2500 20 ici donc là les Noirs aussi
donc on va un peu
moins intéressant
pour lui
et puis voilà ni mal qui a 6 points qui
qui vient de perdre en perdition là dans
ce tournoi là mais pareil il sera
dangereux en glisse très clairement il y
a pas mal franchement on te voit le
tableau là franchement
on a vraiment envie de de voir ce qui va
se passer on a hâte de voir ce qui se
passe il reste deux rondes deux rondes
et il y aura un champion du monde de
rapides et Magnus vient de se tirer une
balle dans le pied mais il est loin
d'être enterré
c'est ça alors pourquoi est-ce que sur
le stream on ne voit plus la caméra
c'est une belle question pourquoi la
caméra
la caméra
je ne sais pas je vais vous mettre la
caméra de carrossière
par cette fin de tournoi et on le
comprend on pourra vous montrer quelques
images et évidemment si la caméra
remarque il est où déjà il joue
il joue vite on ira voir une façon là
c'est important de voir un peu de voir
un peu tout ce qui se passe
lors de cette ronde très importante là
pour pour
pas tous les joueurs c'est vraiment la
ronde à ne pas rater
[Musique]
juste ouais j'ai un problème de caméra
pour pourquoi la caméra a disparu elle
est revenue hein oui non mais j'ai
changé de caméra
j'en ai 5 mais j'en ai une qui ne marche
plus
là je ne peux rien
match attention un peu de fatigue on l'a
vu dans le rondes précédentes des
erreurs
et il faudra rééditer ça dans les deux
dernières rondes qui sont les plus
importantes qui vont définir le tournoi
des joueurs
ces deux derniers rondes vous finissez
sur deux sur deux tournois hyper cool et
vous en perdez une des deux déjà c'est
quasiment quasiment foutu il y a plus de
marge même ceux qui sont dans les trois
premiers il y a plus de marge parce que
il s'attendent à faire une grosse place
il faut confirmer on a vu un meuble pour
Magnus même avec 10 minutes d'avance mec
une position stable
ça peut être ça peut être chaud
je vais vous mettre la petite
la petite caméra en grand là
pour attendre que les joueurs arrivent
donc on a vu Carolin qui faisait 100 pas
à côté de l'échiquier donc ça c'est la
table numéro 2
et qui joue à côté d'ailleurs
table 2 c'est Fed OCF et 45
[Musique]
si je fais ça
technique vous voyez il vous offre ses
images je vous ai changé regardez je
vous ai mis le tableur donc écran sans
les joueurs mais ça il peut pas
grand-chose
qui a buggé malheureusement ah non elle
est revenue
toute la salle je peux vous la mettre
vous la voyez c'est la salle
on a un peu du mal à reconnaître les
joueurs ah ça y est on voyait on voit
bien
à droite on va à Paris
danse au milieu de la salle
dont chaque
qui arrive aussi
on voit qu'il y en a qui sont fatigués
on connaît tous les joueurs avec Kevin
normalement
il y a que du monstre
on a Christopher ou
pardon qui était au bout
de Moussa en fond qui arrive avec sa
bouteille d'eau
qui va aller se s'asseoir pour pour la
partie
qu'est-ce qu'on a encore
[Musique]
moi je suis en direct
bien sûr j'ai compris après
qui est très concentré qui meurt qui
meurt qui fait le tournoi de sa vie
et qui est très concentré
il a très bien joué aujourd'hui et c'est
pris une raclée avec carrossan mais il
est encore été là dans les rondes
précédents
[Musique]
la partie
donc mvl et amine Bassem qui se
connaissent bien qui sont Clichy enfin
qui était ensemble Clichy
[Musique]
et depuis que mvl est à raniera français
je crois qu'elle avait OK
confortable tu peux te dire que par
contre c'est un joueur assez rugueux
j'en avais fait les frais en top quand
je l'avais joué il m'a mis une bonne
raclette on en parle toujours à 2700
noir peuvent vous dire qu'il faut pas
s'attendre à une partie facile et ça
n'avait pas été le cas
il avait troué mon Gambie dame refusé
voilà complètement ça ait pris l'autre
toute part j'ai essayé de coper mais ça
n'a pas ça n'a pas suffi
qui se balade aussi
alors les filles je les connais un peu
moins je crois que c'est côté là
devant j'ai pas bien vu
[Musique]
une grosse caisse quand il avait 13 ans
multiple Champion du monde de mémoire
jeune il avait 13 ans et 2400
et donc là on a vite dit et Kemer les
deux les deux jeunes joueurs qui
s'affrontent
l'idée qui fait un tournoi très sérieux
et à quelle heure qui fait un excellent
tournoi largement au-dessus de son de
son élo actuel
voilà nouvelle génération qui monte avec
double
on l'a vu dans les open français quand
il était beaucoup plus jeune que mère
autour de 2400
oublier on oublie souvent mais les
jeunes qui qui sont extraordinairesment
forts extrêmement précoces ce sont des
jeunes qui ont joué tout le temps depuis
leur plus jeune âge c'est à dire que bon
ils vont à l'école et dès qu'ils ont une
semaine de vacances et une semaine de
tournoi d'échec en fait
ce sont des machines à jouer c'est
obligatoire si vous voulez passer à
passer un cap aux échecs même si vous
êtes trop fort
je crois que c'est Morzine qu'on voit
qui va louer
et du coup on les voit tout le temps
dans chaque tournoi même des rapides
même des Blitz hop hop on va en tournoi
alors c'est presque plus facile
d'ailleurs pour les jeunes de stage là
qui ont pas des contraintes fortes et
même tous les autres joueurs pro ou les
joueuses des fois cumulent des activités
pro etc et on dévie et remplis avec les
échecs parce que c'est pas facile de
cumuler les vies les vies perso c'est
des engagements très très forts et
du coup c'est aussi admirable au service
d'une passion parce qu'on a dit être
joueur d'échecs
tu vois regarde un scène qui qui n'est
pas encore arrivé pression psychologique
pression psychologique sur
sur Caravana
on va voir on va mettre un petit
échiquet en attendant peut-être que
meridith je sais pas qu'est-ce que tu en
penses tout on va en apprendre
alors on a demandé quand même gamer donc
si vous voulez on peut on peut aller
voir caméra rapidement voir ce qui se
passe mais on va pas mal changer parce
que là avec plein de parties qui sont
intéressantes donc je vous changer la
vue je vous mets du coup la caméra de
gamer je pense que c'est le mieux
maximum Maximus nous pose pensez-vous
qu'à 40 ans il est possible d'obtenir un
super niveau quand on débute de presque
rien ça dépend si tu dis super niveau
est-ce que 25 super niveau qui est pour
moi presque le max dans dans le cactus
site et je parle de ça avec un
investissement colossal
donc si c'est mettre je ne pense pas
parfum il y a toujours des
contre-exemples qui pour exister mais
c'est extrêmement rare surtout que tu me
dis on part de rien
faut savoir que bon moi j'ai démarré les
échecs à 7 ans en club et je suis passé
maître à 20 ans
voilà j'aurais pu passer mettre à 17 18
ans j'ai raté un point hello le titre
mais
c'est long quand même tu vois il faut 10
ans quoi il faut 10 ans et en partant en
allant jeune quoi
je fais une erreur de scène voilà vous
avez vu la scène où j'étais tout seul
max pour moi en partant de rien ça
dépend si tu joues tous les jours ou pas
et si tu es entraîné ça dépend de la
structuration que tu mets en place
autour
si tu es entre guillemets rentiers et
avec une vie perso qui te permet de
concilier en fait faudrait en faire
autant qu'un pro quasiment et en étant
accompagné
alors donc
cette partie c'est une position assez
tranquille une sorte d'anglaise
ou une Rhétie assez tranquille
dans ce genre de position
mais on n'est pas obligé de forcer le
destin tout de suite
boum boum Charlie
[Musique]
il faudra combien de temps à tout pour
passer mettre avec un investissement
colossal c'est normal que ce soit barré
j'ai pas très bien compris tu sais que
techniquement
j'ai vu un message supprimé en tout cas
Charlie
charlie avait été assez discret depuis
un moment et il est comme le revenu au
Beaumont
merci à toi Charlie pour ces bons
moments que tu nous fais passer
heureusement qu'ils sont là les copains
et pour te soutenir dans ces moments
difficiles
donc cavalier C6 soit là parce que les
Noirs menacés des cartes en fait
naturellement il y a des petites choses
il y a des petits guilis donc tu joues
en fait tu vas sûrement jouer ce contre
un pion contre un pion isolé avec
souvent un pion prend un cavaler prend
des quatre et derrière il y a une partie
qui est très connue là dessus sur
l'option isolé un parti commun dans
toutes les écoles
des cartes étaient peut-être un petit
peu
peut-être un peu tôt mes petits rois
je peux vous dire que des quatre risques
d'être joué par les Blancs je pense que
c'est la structure qu'il va choisir
parce que Decathlon noir ça a l'air
beaucoup beaucoup trop ambitieux
en plus
donc là on va sûrement voir un petit
fouetisme plutôt que cette généralement
avec des cartes entraînement prise
cavalier prend et petit rock qui devrait
tout à fait être joué après
des fois qu'ils sont joués mais c'est
vrai que les pions pendant là c'est
quand même une faiblesse j'ai
l'impression on pourra décider de la
position ON touchera rien avec les
Blancs on fracasse T3 l'amélioration des
tours etc et du coup un moment
la structure sera défavorable soit les
pions sur le pion isolé et c'est les
blancs qui décideront donc attention
c'est ça
prise prise on a chacun un pion isolé
mais l'impression que quand même les
blancs au niveau développement ils sont
quand même plus
[Musique]
développés peut-être fou ces quatre
petits robes juste et dire qu'après je
sens ma pièce puis on est quatre il sera
en vie
c'est sûrement ce que je veux jouer en
tout cas
c'est parti je trouve ça très
intéressant son coup de jouer à D4 il a
joué j'y croyais pas un par un peu par
principe si tu veux mais
maintenant faut qu'on prouve ce qu'on a
dit avant donc prise de carte prise des
4 tours un fouet pour Rocket
et là voir son joue ce que je pense
qu'on va comme jeu B5
à jouer
préféré
en ces quatre cinq oui par exemple pour
tourser un pour fout des trois pour
sortir les pièces
malheureusement
toutes les pièces dessus
moi je pensais aussi à faire tu sais le
détroit cavaliers 2 et après maintenant
jouer sur casse blanche peut-être mais
je sais pas trop je suis pas du tout
c'est position donc en tout cas on va
voir comment ça joue c'est très
intéressant on avait annoncé et
maintenant les les blancs une bonne
décision à prendre enfin une décision
pas facile en tout cas
on va voir est-ce qu'on va faire un
petit tour des parties là voir un petit
peu ce qui se passe chacun allez c'est
le moment
un peu différent il y a toujours quand
même cette idée de pouvoir manger
il va travailler la structure regardez
les coussins il a mis son fond en G2
pour dominer le fousset 8 qui est parti
en A6 à la pêche
et maintenant on va voir si j'arrive à
travailler le pion des cinq regardez il
est ciblé par 4 pièces blanches en
transparence là ce pion des 5 tout va se
passer là
est-ce que la pression va être
suffisante
mais déjà un jeu très simple c'est très
visuel ce qu'on voit là
c'est donc assez
n'a pas oublié il a mis une grosse
grosse raclette le match était 22 à 4 20
une seule partie dans le match c'est
moche de niveau aussi important entre
les joueurs et du coup
psychologiquement il avait quand même
bien éclaté karena qui doit bien sûr tu
vois psychologiquement c'est dur de bien
sûr un jeu contre un joueur qui t'a mis
qui t'a mis 224
c'est pas si facile que ça
marche facile de l'expérience il est
quand même 8 enfin il est pour l'instant
il sait que qui peut encore être
champion du monde en rapide et que deux
parties voilà c'est pas un masque qui va
durer 4 heures là tu vois c'est juste
pour
les échecs sur le sport au monde où
c'est autorisé pas être sur le terrain
lors du coup d'envoi il y a des règles
de tolérance zéro qui peuvent exister
dans les tournois là c'est souvent fait
d'ailleurs comme il y a un enchaînement
significatif de ronde c'est pas évident
quand même parce que les joueurs après
la partition de budget de se lever il y
a un laps de temps assez court peut-être
de 15 minutes bon
ça va quand même assez vite dans les
parties au niveau ça plus de sens mais
en rapide
c'est un peu normal logistiquement
parlant ou alors faudrait un sas où tu
regroupes les joueurs mais ils ont
simplement besoin quand ça enchaîne
comme ça de s'alimenter etc donc ça
serait pas si évident que ça ça ferait
supporter des contraintes logistiques
importantes à l'organisation je pense
pour que tout se passe bien c'est clair
et là tu vois par exemple aux Olympiques
et ben c'est comme ça c'est tolérance
zéro c'était pas échiquier quand ça
commence et moi tu parles la partie donc
logique enfin c'est pas illogique ce que
nous dit
c'est quand même un c'est un tournoi
quand même un des plus gros tournois qui
qui existe donc tu vois en termes de de
de sérieux tu vois tu peux pas arriver
en retard ça se fait pas trop quoi il y
a plein d'autres peines où tu arrives en
retard etc c'est tu vois mais là quand
même prestige tu peux pas trop faire ça
quoi bien sûr Olympiades du monde ou
truc comme ça
mon tour C8 car personne qui met la
pression là qui est déjà un petit peu
[Musique]
qu'il y a faut prendre surtout de la
séquence DCBC si je mange toujours
on s'arrête je pense je me serais arrêté
à Madame des cinq fraudes oui oui on va
s'arrêter à Dame des cinq et faire fou
aux deux pour attaquer la tour des a
OK et du coup je peux pas manger là
parce que du coup je m'attends en prise
exactement si je fais tour des deux tu
peux manger là mais du coup peut-être
derrière ouais c'est quand même pas mal
ça qui est des quatre parce qu'avait dit
qu'il va venir un peu tout ça mais ça
Magnus un c'est pas le style de la
maison je peux vous le dire
surtout qu'il a tout le temps avant de
définir la structure il a le temps c'est
lui qui met la pression sur l'option
donc il va manger en dessin quand il
aura quand il aura il y aura surtout C8
qui a été joué ici E3 peut-être
qui est assez thématique
et là je crois pas du tout à la position
noire parce que
j'ai très peur ici de voir le problème
sur D5
F4 alors est-ce que tu as b5b4 peut-être
tu me tromper
donc c'est pas si simple encore cette
position
ce qui est intéressant
qu'on va attendre mais ok
bien sûr pour essayer de se créer un peu
passé mais c'est vrai qu'on peut pas
oublier que Ben fait peur quand même
dans ses conséquences qui est faible et
il coûte majorité au centre pour les
blancs actuellement il est à 40 lieux 5
cavaliers prend des 4
qui me permet pas de jouer cavalier E5
tout de suite donc on fait E3 donc du
coup
c'est un vous l'avez vu ça peut être un
coup naturel
on a aussi la séquence des Français 5 B
prend C5 E3 très forte séquence Magnus
il existe il est il regarde quand je
vois
dans les meilleurs conditions possibles
on y a un travail de la position
il est en train d'essayer d'interpréter
la structure est-ce que je touche à rien
est-ce que je définis ce que je joue E3
pour définir dans le meilleur
circonstances c'est très intéressant le
sujet de la structure d'option peut vous
dire que au-delà des capacités
calculatoires des joueurs de haut niveau
c'est l'interprétation des structures en
général avec un petit peu de profondeur
il permet aux joueurs d'exceller donc
c'est là où Magnus est plus fort que ses
adversaires même si sur ces sujets là
des joueurs comme Karana sont hyper
hyper adroits ce sont des génies mais
Carlsen c'est un génie parmi les génies
sur ce sujet là
donc très très belle partie
positionnelle de manus qui est vraiment
dans son élément avec un Fabiano karwana
qui est sur la défensive parce qu'il a
la couleur noire
1 après ah d'accord
pour eux ça va être la partie en ce
qu'on avait vu tout à l'heure x 2 et là
il y aura un petit coup
ça peut être par exemple x 2 dames des 8
mais bon je vois pas trop à la finalité
bon minus veut jouer contre la structure
AC je n'aurais pas fait ce choix là et
justement je suis très intéressé pour
voir comment Carlson ici puisqu'il a
prévu cette position il va traiter donc
ça on va anticiper avec tout à l'heure
et maintenant il a forcément prévu un
coup c'est là le coin important c'est la
clé qu'on n'avait pas nécessairement vu
c'est à dire que là il a trouvé un coup
qui allait maintenir le pressing tas de
tour des deux le coussin
je comprends pas trop le choix en fait
pour tout vous dire je prends ces cinq
je les mets un pion il a découvert donc
je dois manger mais après la prise donc
le cavalier il en décape mais il est pas
si stable que ça parce que le pion quand
même doit rester là dessus il y a
souvent du BK qui peut arriver peut-être
qu'il pense juste faire ça ça et
remettre ou peut-être faire d'argent
donc je dois manger du chou
ou alors je peux aussi manger en D8 mais
4 du coup
je peux pas manger en début parce qu'il
y en a une première fois intermédiaire
enfin il y aurait peut-être la finale
qui est peut-être possible j'y crois pas
trop oui
[Musique]
je vois pas du tout où il trouve
l'avantage
bien sûr
Magnus ici avec tour des deux du coup et
est-ce que c'est pas au moment où j'ai
dit qu'il accélère sur la structure de
pion qui a pris cette décision donc j'ai
hâte de voir ce que je l'ai passé ou pas
c'est quand même un peu chaud parce que
s'il gagne pas avec les Noirs la
dernière il va pas être champion et
comme on sait que Magnus va être
champion ok donc il a joué il a joué on
sait pas ce qui se passe hein parce
qu'il peut y avoir des nuls aussi tu
vois je suis persuadé qu'il a jugé cette
position et qu'il a qui joue pour le
gars c'est pas possible qui joue pour
nul enfin vu ce qu'il avait je crois pas
je pense que Charlie Charlie a des
propos fantaisistes dans dans le chat
stouf qui est des quatre fous des
peut-être
c'est moche mais écoute
j'ai envie de t'empêcher de contrôler en
fait des cages de cavaliers et faire
tourner
avec l'histoire du match de couloir qui
va me sauver ouais mais bon je vois pas
trop en quoi ça te sauve vraiment on va
peut-être juste ça mais j'ai 6 quand
même tu manges là bien sûr je parle mal
du coup là bien sûr je mets un pion sur
15 noir enfin non ça peut pas être ça
c'est pas satisfaisant et là j'ai ça
exagéré
[Musique]
qui l'a fait aussi logique vous gardez
la colonne t ouverte mais
parce que cavaler des quatre
l'inconvénient c'est que j'ai plutôt
envie de
5 essences quand même pour moi mais moi
aussi mais
[Musique]
cap je sais pas non il y a
été joué par 45
peut-être qu'ils sont moi je pense que
ça risque de faire ça ça ça ça
est nul
ça risque de faire un truc comme ça
après qu'elle va les prendre c'est pas
obligatoire pour l'instant
du crédit à la thèse de Charlie alors
malheureusement oui de dire ça
tournedos j'ai peut-être dû tourner
attention quand même
incroyable
si c'est pas forcément un coup
S c'est promis il va y avoir du pack sur
la plateforme mais là il y a plus de
commentaires de de championnat du monde
de rapides et de blit de ce moment pas
tout faire en même temps avec tout on a
un peu les mêmes contraintes
généralement quand ça sort pas tout de
suite c'est que c'est qu'on est sur
d'autres choses mais il y en aura à peu
près un par mois à partir de janvier
voilà qui qui vont sortir comme ça tu
sais en avant-première
à comprendre
on est comme toi on a du mal à
comprendre son
faute de calcul et du coup il est obligé
de jouer ça c'est possible qu'il a raté
à ce moment-là le style en plus c'est
pas le style mais écoute il vient de
oui oui je suis d'accord avec toi pour
l'étiquette j'arrive pas à comprendre
tout non plus on est coincé en fait
il y a que en fait finalement il y a que
Charlie qui avait compris le coup de
Carlson parce qu'il est habitué à ce
genre de coup au niveau structurel
mvl on va aller voir ce qui se passe
mais il a 7 points vite fait on va voir
ce qu'il arrive à recoller là il est en
train de s'activer dangereusement
je préfère les Noirs ça y est je
commence à préférer le noir alors Maxime
espagnol italienne enfin j'ai vu
une Espagnole qui l'avait battu à amine
Bassem de mémoire une vraie raclée
ok vous voyez que ce soit une Espagnole
ou une italienne c'est souvent les mêmes
plans qui prédominent
donc là à tout moment
avec des histoires de maths de toujours
un F5
mais bon
qui est un petit peu plus agréable et
compliqué donc c'est totalement dans son
[Musique]
facilités de pièces pour Maxime
par rapport au blender du match ben moi
je j'aurais dit non mais on avait dit
que non mais ça partait pour l'instant
il peut convaincante
il a raison et il nous incitait Top 12 à
Brest mais c'est ça tu as tout à fait
raison c'est ça ok surtout prends ça qui
peut y avoir du gaval des deux qui peut
être très très grave pour pour 45 du
coup tu vois qu'un scène qui qui est pas
content
on le voit à la caméra
carne qui est pas du tout content et je
pense qu'il est quitté il a l'attitude
un peu du genre tissé
bizarre parce que ouais il est tenté
tout le temps non il a fait un super
temps même là il fait un bonbon encore
bien sûr faut pas qu'il a fait un
tournoi extraordinaire mais une gaffe en
un coup voilà c'est un peu dans le
tournoi une gaffe dans tous les coups
qu'il a joué il avait un mauvais coup ça
remet pas mal de choses en cause bon là
il doit essayer de faire nul maintenant
il sait il a la tête basse mais
finalement
je pense je penche plus pour la thèse
d'une bêtise puisque 45 là devrait être
contente sa position il est vraiment
donc en fait on vous confirme que
Charlie c'était trompé et que le
discours était bien fantaisiste je pense
qu'il a juste il a raté plein de choses
je sais pas à quel point il a raté
autant apprécié
bon après cette position est-ce qu'elle
est vraiment dangereuse pour les blancs
bon ça reste dangereux mais est-ce que
si personne ne veut vraiment pas la
perdre ce qui peut ne pas la perdre
[Musique]
c'est quoi
il joue ça ok bon intermédiaire et
OK et chaque forcée là je sens large pas
défendre et attention qu'elle fout en
prison donc là soit tu bouges le roi ce
qui m'a pas l'air très bien soit tu
bouges ton fou
il faut trouver une case il faut trouver
une case et là tu vas perdre depuis en
plus tu vois F2 et B2 peut-être fou ok
sur la colonne de la tour c'est quand
même hyper risqué
ça et après tu reviens avec ton fou
voilà je reviens et le cavalier soit en
D1 soit en Détroit la fourchette de
cases
de la fourchette de cases
en fait je voulais bien sûr taper sur
normal
pousser si c'est pas c'est quoi ce coup
vous aussi
le X 8 c'est du délire
mais par contre j'aurais pas les
problèmes quoi c'est à dire que il doit
y avoir quelque chose on voit que la
jauge nous indique
sur
l'échecs
ça fait sens donc c'est pas possible sur
et sur
la partie cavalier ouais bien vu
donc on va assister B2 je pense
contrôle la case des 5 les noirs sont
légèrement mieux mais sans doute que
c'est pas assez
bon ça risque de faire nul mais bon car
scène ils vont faire nul bon choix
pratique de Carlson quand même qui sera
trappe mais après avoir
dire comme il ira pas c'est pas c'est
pas le cas mais fais comme une grosse
erreur d'appréciation dans les
structures d'options là où il excelle on
l'a fait annoncé on vient dire que
carlossen faisait jamais d'erreur de GAF
tactique il en a fait une larme
précédente à 10 minutes d'avance au
temps une position hyper facile à jouer
à ne pas perdre et là avec les Blancs il
vient de gâcher une position confortable
de manière assez ahurissante en fait
pour lui parce que c'est toute sa
carrière il l'a construit sur des
positions comme comme il a eu et là il a
fait une très très grosse erreur de
d'appréciation
comme ça
je pense
on va bientôt avoir 20 nul il faut
encore défendre mais
là on les fait comprendre
tu as pas le temps du coup d'attaquer
là-bas
peut-être juste tu auras 8
tu manges ici je mets le fou en fait
c'est le tour à 8 et que tu manges avec
la tension qui peut avancer
je viens de voir
chaque fourchette je perds le fou je ne
peux pas venir défendre ce fou attention
qu'il y a 8
c'est vraiment dur pour lui c'est lui
qui l'a trouvé à tous les coups de
défense pour faire nul
pour cette fois c'est un bon coup j'aime
bien car elle va les prendre F2 mais au
moins les pièces reviennent en jeu et on
peut essayer de défendre même si c'est
le coup normal il faut le jouer
en plus le petit échec salvateur en H3 à
tout moment
le Fou est meilleur que le cavalier dans
ce type de position avec deux îlots 1
sur la dame enfin bon il y a un pion de
chacun sur les dames des pions sur les
lois malheureusement il y a quand même
le pion de moins
OK
[Musique]
à une pression assez confortable tour D1
apparemment c'est une gaffe avec prise
cavalier prend fou F5
et c'était quoi ah oui d'accord
je vous le montre ici
dans cette position qui défend achète et
qui est contre-attaque pour l'initiative
à 6 x 7 il y avait roi F8
et pas ridicule assurément
bien joué bien joué pagno tu as trouvé
c'est ça
m'a du couloir et du coup il se passait
quoi
on peut prendre le cavalier mais en fait
c'est marrant
amine a trouvé mais il a oublié la la
pointe on va dire c'est ça
ils sont des vrais complications assez
importantes aussi dans cette variante
les noirs qui sont quand même plus
actifs cette pollution quand tu as des
pièces blanches
un détroit cavalier E5 tel C4 C5 qui
peut arriver et venir défendre ce pion
attention souvent rapide on surjou hein
c'est ce que Maxime propose ici avec
cette partie où il a quand même 3
minutes d'avance autant donc il essaie
de faire peur amine bassems
qui sont quand même embuscade juste
derrière juste derrière Carsen il y a
exactement je vais vous mettre leur
caméra si je pense bien raison celle-là
je vous ai mis
vous voyez l'espace plus important côté
blanc et surtout le fou des trois qui
domine le fou B7 qui est le principal
déséquilibre de la position c'est ça
c'est ça et du coup dans la partie du
coup ici c'est bon un avantage blanc on
voit que le plan a 6 qui me faiblesse
quand la partie contre de Maxime qu'on a
vu
contre c'était qu'on s'appelait il y a
que le boef
un petit peu le même genre voilà c'est
pas du tout le même structure mais on va
juste ça en fait
Damas 3 pour essayer de compliquer un
peu la sauce d'aller manger le pion à 5
aussi là on est en plus artemief qui est
mal au temps qui a tout entre 6,50 il
peut aussi avoir il faut les tactiques à
base de cavaliers B5 ou de cavalier pour
195 attention aux découvertes qui
pourraient qui pourrait être dangereuse
[Musique]
la question
tu as le temps de partir regardez on
s'intéressant
[Musique]
je ne peux pas jouer mais fais attention
quand même à ce genre de chose c'est
peut-être tactique envoyé quand il y a
des vis-à-vis comme ça ça peut vraiment
arriver même qu'elle va les prendre des
cinq ça pourrait être une idée mais le
problème ce sont cavaler prendre un
dingue et ben jusqu'à valait prendre le
sac qui va défendre la force 7 donc ça
ne marchera pas mais attention à ce
thème là et plusieurs demandes des
nouvelles de Carlsen qui était en
difficulté contre Fabiano carwana après
avoir donné une partie en un quarté MF
et je pense qu'il a qu'il a blender un
peu dans la partie parce que il a joué
des coups assez incompréhensible et une
position avec un bon avantage il a voulu
simplifier et finalement il se retrouve
dans une position où il est où il est
très mal on peut en tourner à avoir si
vous voulez 45 rapidement je vais vous
mettre la caméra déjà pendant ce temps
là
et voilà claque un scène
allez blanche cette édition
donc il va manger à 5 ça risque de faire
nul quand même mais vous voyez que les
pièces noires sera quand même
hyperactives et du coup c'est pas aussi
simple que ça il a trouvé la bonne
séquence un H4 pour fixer le cavalier
même en H3 et elle pourra pas faire trop
de mal
et maintenant il part il part pour
simplifier la position à l'aile dame
alors par rapport à
firouza non on a on a on a aucune
explication on ne sait pas donc on
imagine que tu vois il a pas non plus le
speech on imagine que tout ce qui est
Internet ou tout ce qui est Blitz il
évite il est plutôt de faire des parties
enfin en tout cas ils s'entraînent je
pense pour les parties pour les parties
à cadence lente c'est ce que
on traduit après je ne sais pas si c'est
vraiment ça la raison mais en tout cas
non il est pas là et on n'a pas dit
d'explication après les Chinois il y en
a des Chinois
mais c'est vrai qu'après les Chinois on
les voit pas dans les plus trop les
Chinois dans le monde des échecs ça va
être trop tombant comme ça
après au top niveau ben il manque aussi
bon
sur le title il a joué hier
ah oui j'ai pas vu qu'il avait joué là
c'est un soir 5h
on sait qu'il aime ça quand même le jeu
sur internet mais après tu décompress un
petit peu c'est genre deux heures tu
vois c'est facile fin facile c'est un
truc tu peux faire en
allant sur tscom quoi là pour le coup le
tournoi ben ça a quand même 5 jours
intense de plus de thérapie il faut
aller jusque là-bas etc bon voilà
différent l'investissement n'est pas le
même c'est pas pareil là justement je
pense pour le café tu faisais là je veux
décompresser voilà donc voilà
tout simplement
[Musique]
que
mvl a dans le tournoi il a fait 11
parties il a 7 points sur 11 pour
l'instant
connu mieux il a hypothéqué ses chances
et on va voir
une répétition voilà
complètement blender et qui fait quand
même nul quelques coups après ça montre
à quel point quand même il est fort il a
trouvé la bonne
le bon le bon setup pour pas
pour ne pas perdre donc ça fait nul les
gardiennes qui se pensent soulager de
faire nul parce que il a il avait bien
blender alors c'est assez bizarre ce
qu'il avait fait il avait une position
ici avec avec une belle pression sur la
sur le pont des cinq et la colonne vert
c'est très bizarre et il a tout échangé
pour rentrer dans cette finale
et juste mauvaise quoi enfin il a les
pièces inactive et les pièces noires
c'est complètement incompréhensible mais
bon après il faisait un petit peu à la
tête à la caméra donc mais il joue
encore la dernière ronde pour le titre
quoi c'est ça qui est malgré deux
parties à tête suite c'est ça pour
montrer l'avance qu'il avait on va aller
voir comme rapidement
artémia fait d'OCS c'est la partie qui
est importante parce qu'au final c'est
égalité avec caraxel c'est Artémis avec
gagne cette partie avec les noirs et ben
écoute il prend la tête il est il est
pas du tout en train de presser fedocef
au contraire c'est tout l'inverse autant
à la pendule que sur la position ou ben
comme tu le disais on a plutôt une
position à deux résultats sauvegarde
d'un des joueurs on sait qu'en rapide
c'est déjà arrivé on sait que les
joueurs sont fatigués donc tout peut se
passer mais quand même avantage a fait
dossiere qui bien son petit artemief
qui a plus de 18 secondes à la pendule
ça fait ça fait peur quand même
donc je pense pas Carson soit très
inquiet dans cette partie en tout cas
non c'est le plus dangereux et après ça
sera donc Kemer et vides l'autre partie
à suivre d'ailleurs on va dans les
caméras puis on va sur la caméra de
scène qui vient jeter un oeil sur la
partie de d'artemief et
philosophe qui vient de partir bien sûr
il est concerné il est pas là pour
décorer et puis ça doit l'ennuyer
fortement psychologiquement d'avoir
offert Artémis un demi point entier
puisque au lieu de faire nul il a perdu
contre artemiev
nul au moins d'ailleurs donc il faudrait
pas carterief lui fasse le coup de
gagner cette partie qu'on fait d'Oc
[Musique]
amer nous amener plusieurs fois dans le
chat bien sûr gamer qui joue vite qui
est mort qui fait un super super tournoi
d'ailleurs il a une belle position
contre deux résultats je pense pour midi
qui a un roi très faible et une
structure de pion bien dégueu tout à
l'heure on parlait des des
îlots de pions les groupes de pions j'en
ai un deux mers il mérite depuis le
début du tournoi
que des pions faibles confidentiel on
rappelle par le bas qui a été bon qui a
été là qui a fait un tournoi très
sérieux et très bon aussi bien sûr et
c'est vrai que gamer c'est un tournoi
très impressionnant qu'il a fait depuis
le début c'est devant tout le temps
c'est pas pareil d'ailleurs au départage
c'est pas la même chose mais je pense
que si Kemer est sérieux dans cette
partie la gagnera
une minute d'avance
c'est presque gain mais sans doute il a
calculé ah on a eu les Vals et c'est
bien ce que je pensais
4 m'inspire quand même après j'ai du mal
à voir échec là et chaque gagne la truc
donc pourquoi je suis
donc là ça a été joué et là il y a
plusieurs choses qui ont un air
intéressantes
le sauvetage
donc
et revient donc tourage 4 semble être le
coup le plus indiqué ici parce que
chaque roi là tu as plus d'échec je me
lasse mat en un coup on aurait cinq et
dames G7 pour résister je crois que ça
va être un peu moins d'ailleurs je vais
voir si j'ai la caméra qui qui
je voulais vous la mettre la caméra on
arrive au meilleur moment pour vous
montrer que visite
et dans une position désespérée contre
Vincent Kemer qui est là l'énorme
surprise du tournoi donc l'idée sympa là
dame prend F5 damasha et dames G7 mais
bon ça ne suffira pas j'ai un pion de
moins une grosse pubelle qui va arriver
regardez
aussi qui serait encore pire je crois
H7 ça gagnerait parce que dame prend ce
qu'il a fait
voilà très efficace aussi en fait il va
réussir quasiment changer d'arme en plus
c'est complètement gagnant qui est mort
qui va gagner la partie et
qui va se mettre en je crois qu'il aille
il rattrape le groupe de tête avec moi